Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. The new BMO, V.I. Porter MasterCard, is your ticket to more.
More perks, more points, more flights, more of all the things you want in a travel reward, cards card and then some get your ticket to more with the new bemo v i porter master card and get up to twenty four hundred dollars in value in your first thirteen months terms and conditions apply visit bemo dot com slash the i porter to learn more searchlight pictures presents the roses only in theaters friday from the director of meet the parents and the writer of poor things comes the roses starring academy award winner olivia coleman academy award nominee bened Cumberbatch, Andy Samburg, Kate McKinnon, and Alison Janney. A hilarious new comedy,
filled with drama, excitement, and a little bit of hatred, proving that marriage isn't always a bed of roses. See the roses only in theaters Friday. Get tickets now. The Germans were all around us. One could see them in the wood, and they were shooting quite close. The man who finally got me was about 15 to 20 yards away. His bullet was like a tremendous punch. Then everything was quiet, and a deep piece fell upon the wood. It was very dreamlike. After about an hour and a half, I suppose, a German with a red beard with the sun shining on his helmet and bayonet, came up, looking like an angel of death. I inquired in broken but polite German what he proposed to do next.
After reading the English papers and seeing the way he was handling his bayonet, it seemed to me that there was going to be another atrocity. He was extraordinarily kind and polite. He put something under my head, offered me wine, water and cigarettes. He said, We send Cameradon. Another German soldier came up and said, have I didn't just stay in England? I said, we obeyed orders, just as you do. That was the diary of the British officer and MP Albury Herbert. And he sounds a tremendous chap, Dominic, and exactly the calibre of man that I expect to be serving as an officer in his majesty's forces in the First World War. So he's like you, isn't he? He's a bailiol man who did history.
Yeah. He got a first in history. He became a conservative MP. he's a great travel writer and splendidly he was twice offered the throne of Albania there's a lot of British people who get offered the throne of Albania
CB Fry the great cricketer and an athlete the Albanians just they just want to give it away so in 1914 this bloke Aubrey Herbert actually came quite close to accepting the throne of Albania
but his family friend Herbert Henry Asquith said no I don't think that's a good idea God I bet he's being prodded at with a bayonet he wished he'd done it Yeah. So he joined the Irish Guards in August 1914. He was sent with a British expeditionary force to France. And what he's describing here is the Battle of Mons, which is the first British engagement of the war. And he was wounded and he was briefly taken prisoner. But then later, I think, escaped or was rescued. Anyway, he had an amazing war. And we'll come back to that battle in today's episode. Because last time, Tom, we looked at the German invasion of Belgium, didn't we? And this time, at last, we come to our own beloved country. and to the French, and what the British and French are getting up to against the Germans on the Western Front.
Now, before the war, everybody had said it will be ghastly. It's a complete myth that people didn't know how murderous it would be. And we talked last time about how the Germans are quite pessimistic and apocalyptic going into the war. Kind of Nietzschean despair. Yeah. But that's shared in London. Asquith, it will be a real Armageddon. Sir Edward Gray, it will be the greatest catastrophe.
the world has ever seen. Winston Churchill, who's very keen on the war, is keen on the war, despite the fact that he says it will be a calamity for civilised Europe. So, you know, people know what's coming. But maybe for Churchill, that's a positive. Yes, exactly. But I guess, so even Churchill, right, Churchill knew what war was like. He'd fought in countless little wars. He'd fought in the Sudan. It'd fought in the Boer War. But these colonial wars, I mean, they're not comparable, are they, to the full unleashing of industrial Armageddon? No, because the forces that will be at play in the next few months on the Western Front, two million Germans, two million Frenchmen, 100,000 Belgians,
and then actually is a very much smaller contingent, only 80,000 men of the British Expeditionary Force. I mean, these are vast numbers, colossal numbers, by the standards of colonial wars. You could add many colonial wars together and you wouldn't come close. The small signs of the British Expeditionary Force reflects our proud island tradition of disdaining standing armies. It's important to mention that early, isn't it? Our love of liberty. Exactly. And what's also fascinating about this, especially for military historians, is, of course, it's technologically poised between old and new.
So all sides enter the war with tens of thousands of cavalrymen, people with kind of breastplates and swords and kind of plumed helmets. But this will be a war of barbed wire and machine guns and shells and trenches. which change everything. And to give you a sense of the sort of death toll that we'll be talking about today, on a single day in August 1914,
the 22nd of August, more Frenchmen were killed than the British lost in the entire Crimean War or the entire Burr War and that's just in one day. And might that reflect the fact that the British had actually fought
in the Burr War and so were to that degree familiar with what could be done on a modern battlefield, and they had adopted their car key, whereas the French are still galloping around like it's Napoleonic wars. Yeah, well, we'll come to this. I mean, this is a huge thing with the French. They have these fantastic, multi-coloured Napoleonic kind of uniforms.
Breast plates and everything, yeah. Exactly. But let's begin in London. So, Britain's ultimatum to Germany had expired at 11 o'clock on the evening of Tuesday, the 4th of August. Basically, you have to clear out of Belgium. The ultimatum expires. There's all people singing the national anthem.
and whatnot outside, Downing Street. It's not till the next day, with his customary urgency that Herbert Henry Asquith convenes his war council. So there's four key ministers. They're Asquith, Gray, Churchill and Richard Haldane, who had basically been the war minister who had built up the army, and the first sea lord Prince Louis of Battenberg and 12 army generals. And the question is, are we going to send an army to Europe? Now, most people know, because they know how the First World War played out. But actually at the time, it seemed obvious probably that we wouldn't. Because just as you said, Britain has always been a naval power. Britain is the only major European combatant that doesn't have a system of compulsory military service. Britain is
unique in having a minuscule professional army. Only 250,000 men. And half of them are overseas. They're in Africa or they're in India. Or they're in, you know, they're garrisoned. far flung across the globe. So most people think, or did many people think, Britain probably will stay out of the land war, as we had done so often in the 18th century or in the Napoleonic Wars. So the most powerful press baron in the land is Lord Northcliffe. He owns the Times and the Mail. He is arguably more powerful than 99% of politicians. And he said to his editors that day, what is this I hear about a British expeditionary force for France? We have a superb fleet, which will give all the assistance in its power.
but I will not support the sending out of this country of a single British soldier. Not a single soldier will go with my consent. Say so in the paper tomorrow. Actually, Northcliff then changes his tune, basically because this war council agrees that they will send troops. And one of the key voices in this war council arguing we have to send troops is a man we've had before on the rest of his history, at the very end of his life, Sir Henry Wilson.
So the guy who gets assassinated thereby precipitating the Irish Civil War. Exactly. So Henry Wilson at this stage is a very important voice in Britain's planning. And he says at this meeting, we have promised the French, we'll send troops to help them. We can't let them down. And so Henry Wilson also points out, he says, you know, he knows that for the Germans, the clock is ticking. He says the Germans are going to fall on France in the next few weeks, if not the next few days. And the French will need all the help that they can get. Because if Paris gets captured, then effectively the war is over for Britain as well. He says we just have to, even though we've only got a small force, we just need to do our bit. So they agree they will send this British expeditionary force, and it's the BEF, one cavalry division, four infantry divisions, 80,000 people. Is this more of a marker, though, to the French, of commitment, rather than actually, you know, a hard kind of support? I think so. I think it's nice to have it. And I think in British historians, of course, talk a lot about the BEF and what it got up to. and it's not inconsequential, but compared with the gigantic numbers that we talked about earlier.
I mean, we're talking about millions of men, 80,000 men. I mean, it's nice to have them. They're not nothing, but they're not that many. But diplomatically, it's massive. Yeah, diplomatically, it's really important to gesture of support. But on the battlefield, Tom, the German infantry outnumbers the British infantry by 20 to 1. These are the kind of odds that we like in a war. Yes, well, the odds that always favour the British, I think.
enable us to show our pluck. Exactly, because in the Burr War, we probably had too many men. Yes, and so we didn't know what to do, did we? Exactly. We were scrambled. Exactly. By European standards, actually, although there are very few of them, they're very well trained and they're very well equipped.
So the older men and some of the offices are veterans of the Burr War, and they have these rifles, Lee Enfield, 0.303s, which are seen as the best rifles in the world and Vickers machine guns. So actually, they're a very modern kind of, they're an elite force, I think it's fair to say. Black squad of elite men, hand-picked. And very good snipers, aren't they, as well? They are.
They're brilliant shots, the British, I have to say. And the Germans admit this when they first meet them at Montes. Now, as for the officers, the officers obviously get a terrible press for the rest of the century. And everybody says, oh, lions led by donkeys, all of this kind of thing. Everyone laughs at their mustaches and their public school slang. And they're all called biffo or something. And they, you know, went to Radley or whatever. I love the advert that gets posted in the first week of the war by a chap looking to set up his own private regiment.
Preference will be given to public school men of good appearance and address. You'll know exactly what they look like because they'll have these very neatly trimmed moustaches. And we talked in the previous episode how every nation, the fighting men are defined by their moustaches. But the British moustaches are neater, I think, by and large, aren't they? They're the best. The officers are greatly introduced and caricatured. However, one officer, who is a bit sub-ideal, is unfortunately. Field Marshal Sir John French
So Field Marshal Sir John French Is an Anglo-Irish cavalry commander Now he had been a great hero He'd serve a great distinction in the Burr War Well Dominic we've met him Also in the Irish Yes of course He almost gets blown up
By an IRA ambush Yeah he didn't massively cover himself In Glory in Ireland as I recall No he's hopeless there as well Yeah So he is a huge womanizer And he is a man of incredibly fierce opinions Now I know you love the book
By Barbara Tuckman the Guns of August. It was the first book I read about this as a child, and I still hold a candle for it. I know that historians of the First World War despise it, but it made it exciting to me. I think it basically is a brilliant work of fiction. I think is how most historians would describe it.
She's very funny at these little pen portraits, so she says of Sir John French, he was short stocky in Florida, his apoplectic expression, combined with the tight cavalryman's stock, which he affected in place of collar and tie gave him the appearance of being perpetually on the verge of choking, as indeed he was emotionally, if not physically. So he's a great cavalryman, but he's never commanded a large, I mean, this isn't even
a large army by the First World War standards, but he's never commanded 80,000 men. He's going to fight in France. He doesn't speak any French. So despite being called French, there's no nominative determinism there? Not at all because he regards the French. with absolute contempt. So this is Sir John talking about the French generals. There are a low lot,
and one always has to remember the class that these French generals mostly come from. It's brilliant that he's been appointed to this command, isn't it? So his French collaborators is like your attitude, Tom, towards our French producer. A respect to my, Theo. No, no, no, I've been very harsh, actually. I know you hold Theo in high regard. So on the 13th of August, the British expeditionary force,
the BF, arrives in France. So they land at Calais, La Avre, and Boulogne, and then they're all in train for Amiens, where they're going to march to Belgium. And they're very excited. There's a great sense of camaraderie and adventure. It's summer. They're abroad. So the younger men have obviously never been abroad, a lot of them.
They're well trained. They're confident. And Aubrey Herbert, who we began with, has a lovely passage in his memoir. He says, we arrived very early. Actually, you do it, Tom. We arrive very early at La Ava in a blazing state. son. As we came in, the French soldiers tumbled out of their barracks and came to cheer us.
Our men had never seen foreign uniforms before, and roared with laughter at their colours. Stephen Burton of the Coldstream Guards rebuked his men. He said, these French troops are our allies. They're going to fight with us against the Germans. Whereupon one man said, poor chaps, they deserve to
be encouraged, and took off his cap and waved it and shouted, Vive L'Ompereur. He was a bit behind the times. Great scenes. Everybody's behaved precisely. on brand there. I think poor French have got four years of this. So the British go
受到鼓舞，脱下帽子挥舞着，大喊“法兰西帝国万岁”。他有点跟不上时代了。宏大的场面。每个人表现得都恰如其分。我认为可怜的法国人还要经历四年这样的日子。所以英国人去了
they go east. At every station they come to there are huge crowds. Aubrey Herbert says we were met by enormous crowds that cheered and would have kissed out of hands if we'd let them. They made speeches and they piled wreaths of flowers upon the colonel who was at first very shy but driven to make a speech. But another lieutenant
他们向东进发。沿途的每一座车站都挤满了大批群众。奥布里·赫伯特说，我们受到了庞大人群的欢迎，他们欢呼着，如果我们允许的话，甚至会亲吻我们的手。他们发表了演讲，并把一堆堆的花环献给那位上校，起初他非常害羞，但还是被逼着发表了讲话。但另一位中尉
a guy called Guy Harcourt Vernon records that when they're going through Amiens He overhears rather ominously some old women talking about them. And one of the old women says, Pover petit Angles, they will be killed. Poor little Englishmen, they will soon be killed. So what about the French?
一个叫盖伊·哈考特·维农的家伙记录说，当他们经过亚眠时，他颇为不祥地无意中听到一些老妇人在谈论他们。其中一个老妇人说：“可怜的小英国人，他们就要送命了。”可怜的小英国人，他们很快就会被杀死的。那么法国人呢？
So France, historically, of course, Europe's greatest land power. And it still is a really serious player. So under President Poincaray, something of a warmonger, I think it's fair to say, They had built up their army. With these Russian salads and everything. Right. The Russian salad guy. The guy had basically gone to St. Petersburg and said, come on, this is the chance.
所以法国，从历史上看，当然是欧洲最强大的陆地强国。而且它现在仍然是一个非常重要的角色。因此，在总统彭加浦的领导下，他有点像个好战分子，我觉得这样说挺公平的，他们一直在扩充军队。带着这些俄罗斯沙拉什么的。没错。那个俄罗斯沙拉家伙。这家伙基本上去了圣彼得堡，然后说，来吧，机会来了。
Let's have a crack at the Austrians and the Germans. He had brought in this new law with more extended military service. So France's army, even before the war, stands at 700,000 men. Relative to population, they're the most militarized of all the great powers. Their army, they don't have as many automatic weapons as the British. They're not completely modernised. But they've got great helmets, haven't they, with plumes on? Yeah, they've spent probably too much time thinking about maintaining their old uniforms.
让我们和奥地利人、德国人干上一场。他颁布了这项延长兵役的新法律。所以法国军队在战前就已经达到了70万人的规模。相对于人口而言，他们是所有大国中最具军国主义色彩的。他们的军队不像英国人那样拥有那么多自动武器。他们还没有完全现代化。但他们有很棒的头盔，不是吗，上面带着羽毛？是的，他们可能花了太多时间考虑如何保持旧军服。
So they haven't adopted the khaki of the British or the grey of the Germans. They've got these long blue over, they look tremendous, these long blue overcoats and red trousers. And their cavalry have this fantastic plumed helmets. And they will go into battle with drums and trumpets beneath waving flags and the commanders lead them in waving their swords and all of this. Now the guy at the head of their army is a very different character
所以他们没有采用英国人的卡其色或德国人的灰色。他们穿着长款蓝色大衣，看起来威风凛凛，这些长款蓝色大衣配着红裤子。他们的骑兵戴着造型奇特、插着羽毛的头盔。他们将在战鼓和小号声中、在飘扬的军旗下投入战斗，指挥官们则挥舞着宝剑带头冲锋，诸如此类。现在，率领这支军队的人是一个非常不同的人物
from Sir John French. He is Joseph Césaire Jouffer who's not an aristocratic. He's a son of a bloke who made barrels in the Pyrenees. And so this is awful for French, isn't it, for Sir John French? Having to talk to the son of a barrel maker. The class that these chaps come from, absolutely ghastly. His British liaison officer said of Jophe,
与约翰·弗朗西斯爵士截然不同。他就是约瑟夫·塞泽尔·茹夫尔，他并非出身贵族。他是一个在比利牛斯山制造木桶的家伙的儿子。所以这对弗朗西斯来说太可怕了，不是吗，对约翰·弗朗西斯爵士来说？不得不和一个做木桶的儿子交谈。这些家伙出身的阶层，简直糟糕透顶。他的英国联络官对茹夫尔的评价是
he was a bulky, slow-moving, loosely built man enclosed that would have been the despair of Savile Row. He looks like a kind of aged obelix, doesn't he? He does, he does exactly. He looks very French. Max Hastings calls him slovenly. Barbara Tuchman says he looks like Father Christmas, which he does a little bit. So he's got a massive white moustache.
他是一个身材魁梧、行动迟缓、体态松散的人，穿着一身会让萨维尔街绝望的衣服。他看起来有点像个年迈的奥贝克斯，不是吗？确实，确实如此。他看起来非常法国化。马克斯·黑斯廷斯称他为邋遢。芭芭拉·塔奇曼说他看起来像圣诞老人，确实有点像。所以他留着一大撮白胡子。
He's got a tight kind of black tunic. He has these massive red breeches and a huge, even in hot weather, sweltering weather, he wears this colossal cape. So he's just kind of dripping with sweats. So his belly that is always kind of trying to strain against the belt, I mean, this is fueled, isn't it, by his very regular eating habits? Exactly. So he has got his headquarters in this little down called Vitri, and he lives with a retired engineer.
他穿着一件紧身的黑色束腰外衣。他穿着巨大的红色马裤，而且即使在天气炎热、闷热的天气里，他也穿着一件巨大的披风。所以他整个人就像是在汗水里浸泡过一样。因此，他的肚子总是试图顶着皮带，我的意思是，这是由他非常规律的饮食习惯维持的，对吧？一点没错。因此，他在一个叫维特里的小镇设立了总部，他和一位退休的工程师住在一起。
He's an engineer himself, military engineer. So he's lodging with this bloke. And every day at 11 o'clock, sharp, no matter what is happening, he goes back to this lodging house for lunch. And lunch is a sort of proper French lunch. starter, then he'll eat a whole roast chicken, bottle of wine, all of this. And he says to his men, nothing, nothing interferes with my routine. He refuses to take telephone calls. So President Pankaree rings him up, I'm not going to waste my time talking to him. You know, he's nothing
他自己就是一名工程师，一名军事工程师。所以他就寄宿在这个家伙家里。每天早晨11点整，无论发生什么事，他都会回到这个寄宿处吃午餐。午餐是一顿地道的法国午餐。头盘，然后他会吃一整只烤鸡、一瓶葡萄酒，诸如此类。他对部下说，没有什么，没有什么能干扰我的日常作息。他拒绝接听电话。所以彭加浦总统给他打电话，我才不会浪费时间跟他说话呢。你知道，他根本不是
like this. He hates the telephone, doesn't he? Yeah, despises it. So rather than telephone, his subordinate officers, he will be driven there, even if it's kind of miles and miles. through crowded roads. In his cape. He's got a guy who won the Grand Prix twice as his driver. And so they hurtle along at enormous speed. I just think it's commendably French. So this guy's off right.
这样的人。他讨厌电话，不是吗？是的，极其鄙视。因此，比起打电话，他宁愿坐车去找他的下属军官，哪怕路程有千山万水。穿过拥挤的道路。穿着他的披风。他的司机是个曾两次赢得大奖赛冠军的牛人。所以他们以极快的速度飞驰而过。我只是觉得这非常具有法国风范。所以这家伙出发了。
He'll arrive every morning to meet his generals and whatnot. And he'll go in. And sometimes he will say nothing. Like literally nothing at all. He just sits there and listens. The meeting ends. He goes off your lunch. And he hasn't said anything, though.
他每天早上都会准时到达，去见他的将军们之类的人。然后他会走进去。有时他会一言不发。真的是一句话也不说。他只是坐在那里听着。会议结束了。他去吃午饭了。而他什么也没说，
whole time. And yet his men think he's brilliant. They call him Papa Jophe. You know, sort of Papa. As we will see, he makes some pretty hideous mistakes. But there is a commendable, he's completely imperturbable, isn't he? He's completely calm. He never loses his call. In every sense of the word, he has bottom. He does. Yes, exactly. But the weird thing is that this bloke who doesn't say anything and it's just stuffing his face with chicken has developed their most reckless plan. So we alluded to this in the first episode the Germans have the Schlieffen plan, the French have a plan called
全程一言不发。然而他的部下却认为他才华横溢。他们叫他“约瑟夫爸爸”。你知道，就像父亲一样。正如我们所见，他犯下了一些相当可怕的错误。但有一种令人赞赏的品质是，他完全处变不惊，对吧？他异常冷静。他从不失态。从字面意义上的各个方面来说，他都很有底气。的确如此。是的，完全正确。但奇怪的是，这个一言不发、只顾往嘴里塞鸡肉的家伙，却制定了他们最鲁莽的计划。所以我们在第一集里提到过这一点，德国人有施里芬计划，法国人有一个叫做
Prontizet, Plan 17. And it's a little bit more straightforward than the German plan. It's basically Yeah, to attack. Just go straight out. Which is a Napoleonic essence of dash and celerity, I guess. And actually, I think we talked about this in the very first series, about the road to the First World War. Before the war, in the years
普龙蒂泽的计划，即第17号计划。它比德国人的计划要直接一些。基本上就是……进攻。直接冲出去。我想这带有拿破仑式的果断和敏捷的精髓。事实上，我想我们在第一季中讨论过关于通往第一次世界大战之路的话题。在战争爆发前的几年里
leading up to it, there'd been a sort of revival of Napoleonic spirit in France. this sort of elin. Yeah, this new patriotism. And the head of the war college, a man who becomes very important to the war, is a guy called Ferdinand Foch. And he is their great strategist, and he helps to advise this plan. Basically, we'll pile up all our forces,
在那之前的岁月里，法国国内曾出现过一种拿破仑精神的复兴。这种所谓的“气势”。是的，这种新的爱国主义。战争学院的院长、一个对这场战争变得非常重要的人，是一个名叫斐迪南·福煦的家伙。他是他们伟大的战略家，他协助制定了这项计划。基本上，我们将集结我们所有的力量，
and we'll just pile across the border into Germany. It would be brilliant. But the reason for that is that one of the reasons that France is so militarized and so hostile to Germany is that the Germans have taken away Alsace and Lorraine in the wake of the Francoisian War. And that must be fundamental to the French way of thinking. And also, it's fundamental to the German way of thinking, isn't it? Because the whole Schlefen plan is predicated on the fact that the French can be relied upon
然后直接冲过边境进入德国。这将是绝妙的。但原因在于，法国之所以如此军事化、对德国如此充满敌意，原因之一是德国人在普法战争之后夺走了阿尔萨斯和洛林。这一定构成了法国人思维方式的根本。而且，这也是德国人思维方式的根本，不是吗？因为整个施里芬计划所依据的前提是，一旦宣战，就可以指望法国人
the moment war is declared to go charging into Alsace and Lorraine. Dead right. The Germans know that basically the French will concentrate their forces on their eastern border and try to pile across. The Germans just need to block them and basically go around them via Belgium. And the French plan, basically to simplify the French plan, they will make two big thrusts. One is straight into Alsace and Lorraine,
会毫不犹豫地冲进阿尔萨斯和洛林。完全正确。德国人知道，基本上法国人会把兵力集中在东部边境，并试图强行冲过去。德国人只需要挡住他们，然后基本上通过比利时绕过他们。而法国人的计划，简单来说，就是发动两次大规模进攻。一次是直插阿尔萨斯和洛林，
and the other is a little bit further north, just south of the Ardennes Forest. They will go through southern Belgium and Luxembourg. However, when they make their first sort of preliminary efforts, the omens are not promising at all. So French dragoons ride into Belgium, and they're immediately driven back by withering German fire. And a cavalryman later said,
另一次则稍微偏北一点，就在阿登森林的正南方。他们将穿过比利时南部和卢森堡。然而，当他们进行最初的初步尝试时，征兆一点也不好。因此，法国龙骑兵骑马进入比利时，随即遭到德国人狂风暴雨般的火力压制，被迫撤退。一位骑兵后来回忆说，
you know, we would charge and the German infantry would just blow us away. and this quote, this is what happened over and over again, perhaps 20 or 30 times. It's the same story further south when the advance guard go into our Sassler Inn. Thousands of French soldiers go in and they're immediately driven back behind the river Milt and they're completely shocked and humiliated. Anyway, reports of this come to Jophe and he says, well, this is tremendous news because this shows that the Germans have concentrated their strength on their flanks
你知道，我们会发起冲锋，而德国步兵会把我们打得粉碎。还有这句话，这情况一次又一次地发生，大概有20到30次之多。当先头部队进入阿尔萨斯-洛林时，南部的情况也是如此。成千上万的法国士兵冲了进去，随即被击退到默兹河后方，他们完全被震惊和羞辱了。无论如何，这些战报传到了茹夫尔那里，他说，这可是个了不起的好消息，因为这表明德国人把兵力集中在了两翼
and their centre will be weak. Because if they're so strong in these first exchanges, that means they must be weak elsewhere. So let's go for the centre. Come on. This is going to be brilliant. And to reiterate, this is what the Germans are banking on. This is how their understanding of French psychology is very, very astute. Yeah.
而他们的中心将是薄弱的。因为如果他们在这些初期的交锋中表现得如此强大，那就意味着他们在其他地方一定很弱。所以我们进攻中心。来吧。这绝对会是一场大胜。再次重申，这就是德国人所押注的。这就是他们对法国心理的理解，非常非常敏锐。是的。
So the French launched their main assault on the 21st of August. Three armies, the third, fourth and fifth, the French armies go onto the offensive in the Ardennes forest. It's a complete and utter disaster. It's a very misty day, so they can't use their reconnaissance air. Of course, the first war in which you could even use reconnaissance aircraft at all. So they go into the forests and they're effectively just walking towards 21 German divisions that are armed with machine guns and howitzers. The French, going through the mist, they're wearing their long blue coats, their red trousers.
因此，法国人在8月21日发起了他们的主要进攻。三支军队，即法国第三、第四和第五集团军，在阿登森林向敌方发起进攻。这简直是一场彻底的灾难。那天雾气弥漫，所以他们无法使用侦察机。当然，这是第一次连侦察机都可以投入使用的战争。于是他们走进森林，基本上就像是在朝着21个装备了机枪和榴弹炮的德国师走去。法国人穿行在浓雾中，穿着他们长长的蓝色大衣和红色的裤子。
The officers are kind of got shining swords and their white-gloved hands. They're singing the Marseillaise. And basically, as soon as they come into view, the Germans say fire. And their machine guns rip through these guys. I mean, what it is, and we've used this comparison before, of those kind of strategy games where the Aztecs end up fighting tanks. It's a bit like that, that it's a Napoleonic army fighting an industrial early 20th century one. Well, there's an account that won by engagement.
军官们手中握着闪闪发光的佩剑，戴着白手套。他们高唱着《马赛曲》。基本上，当他们一进入视线，德国人就下令开火。机枪的火力瞬间将这些人撕裂。我的意思是，那情景，我们以前也用过这个比较，就像那种阿兹特克人最终与坦克作战的战略游戏一样。有点像那样，这是一支拿破仑式的军队在与工业化、20世纪初的军队作战。嗯，有一个关于那场交战的记录。
So this is called the Battle of the Frontiers. There's one account that Max Hastings gives in his book Catastrophe, basically a virtuant on the next morning, the 22nd. So yet again, it's very misty. The French singing their anthem and stuff to identify themselves to each other so they can stick together and they won't have friendly fire.
这被称为边境战役。马克斯·黑斯廷斯在他的书《灾难》中给出了这样一个记录，基本上是关于第二天早上（即22日）的一场交战。所以又一次，大雾弥漫。法国人高唱着他们的国歌之类的内容，好让彼此认出对方，这样他们就能聚在一起，避免发生误伤。
As they're advancing, some of the officers say to their commander, could we possibly be a little bit more cautious? You know, maybe not make quite such a did. What is wrong with you? You know, keep going. They keep going, the fog clears and they see that ahead is higher ground
在他们推进的过程中，一些军官对他们的指挥官说，我们能不能稍微谨慎一点？你知道，或许别做得这么过火？指挥官却说：怎么回事？你们脑子里装的是什么？前进！继续前进。他们继续前进，大雾散去，他们看到前方是高地
with this huge German force ahead of them. And they're like, quick, bring up the guns, bring up the field guns. They get there, they bring up the field guns. And the commanders say to them, the field guns have these kind of shields that the gunners can hide behind while they're shooting. And the officers say, don't bring out their shields for God's sake. A Frenchman must look the enemy in their face. So they don't reuse these shields.
前方是一支庞大的德军部队。他们喊道：快，把大炮拉上来，把野战炮拉上来！他们赶到了，把野战炮拉了上来。指挥官对他们说，这些野战炮有一种防护盾，炮手在射击时可以躲在后面。而军官们却说：看在上帝的份上，别把盾牌拿出来。法国人必须直面敌人的脸。所以他们没有使用这些护盾。
And then the officers say, there's some German machine guns up there, you know, to the infantry. Up and at them, lads, they fix bayonets. The mist is cleared. The sun has come out. It's really hot. Our men in full kit started running heavily up the grassy slope. drums beating, bugles, sounding the charge, we were all shot down before we got to them. I was hit and lay there until I was picked up later.
接着军官们对步兵喊道：看，上面有些德国机枪。冲上去消灭他们，小伙子们！他们上了刺刀。迷雾散尽。太阳出来了。天气真的很热。我们全副武装的人开始沉重地顺着长满草的山坡奔跑，战鼓齐鸣，军号吹响了冲锋号，我们在接近他们之前就全部被击倒了。我中弹了，一直躺在那里，直到后来被人抬走。
And this small stretch of the front, basically we're talking about a field. 5,000 men were shot down. That's five times more than the Germans lost. And what happened at Virton was copied in sort of little engagement all the way across the front. So in the next couple of days, again and again, you have thousands, thousands of Frenchmen, just advancing recklessly towards the German lines with fixed bayonets, like they're fighting the Battle of Waterloo, walking straight into the German machine guns, and the body is just piling and piling up. And the one statistic, the one fact that captures this,
在前线的这一小片区域，基本上也就是一片田野。5000人中弹倒下。这比德国人的损失多出五倍。维尔顿发生的事情在整条战线的各个小规模交战中都在重演。所以在接下来的几天里，一次又一次，成千上万的法国士兵带着刺刀，毫无谋略地朝着德国阵地疯狂推进，就像他们在打滑铁卢战役一样，径直走入德国人的机枪火网中，尸体越堆越高。而有一个统计数据，有一个事实能够概括这一点，
which is just mind-blowing, is that on the second day of the offensive, the 22nd of August, the French lost 27,000 men killed. It's the bloodiest day of the war. It's the bloodiest day of the war. war, far bloody, half as bloody again, has the British lost on the first day of the Somme. And all the time, Jopha is sitting placidly having his chicken outing his lunch. Yeah, exactly. Well, do you know, the guy who'd really come up with the plan is Ferdinand Foch, he lost his son, his only son and his son-in-law on the same day in this offensive.
简直令人震撼，那就是在进攻的第二天，即8月22日，法国阵亡人数高达27000人。这是战争中最血腥的一天。这是战争中最血腥的一天，血腥程度甚至还要高得多，比英国人在索姆河战役第一天的损失惨重一半以上。而与此同时，茹夫尔正安详地坐着，吃着鸡肉，享受着他的午餐。是的，完全正确。你知道吗，那个真正想出这个计划的人是斐迪南·福煦，他在这次进攻中失去了他的儿子，他唯一的儿子和女婿，而且是在同一天。
And that's just one day. this battle goes on for two weeks and across the two weeks the French lost 75,000 men killed and 200,000 men wounded or captured which basically is a tenth of their entire officer class
而这仅仅是一天。这场战役持续了两周，在两周的时间里，法国阵亡75,000人，受伤或被俘200,000人，这基本上相当于他们整个军官阶层的十分之一。
I mean it is one of the great military catastrophes and completely forgotten essentially, certainly in Britain I mean I'm sure not in France but it's amazing listening to that that the whole French army doesn't just implode
我的意思是，这是最伟大的军事灾难之一，而且基本上被彻底遗忘了，当然在英国是这样，我确信在法国肯定没有，但听到这些令人惊叹的是，整个法国军队居然没有直接崩溃。
I was thinking that's actually I mean incredible that they you know they'll be able to muster the the willpower and the discipline to continue fighting for another four years I was just thinking about that when I said oh this is one of the great military catastrophes in history
我当时就在想，实际上——我的意思是，真不可思议，他们居然能（你知道的）振作起意志力和纪律，继续战斗四年。当我刚才说“这是历史上最伟大的军事灾难之一”时，我脑子里正想着这个。
but of course they win the war so you know it can't be that much of a catastrophe well do you I mean you you you think of Verdana's the kind of classic example of yeah the French refusal to surrender to overwhelming losses but this must rank up there as well But you know what? I think in the English-speaking world, the French contribution to the First War is generally massively underestimated, the importance of the France in the First World War. The fact that it's fought on French soil, the French lose so many men. And places like Verdun, the sense of national mobilisation, sacrifice, I think, far greater than anything in Britain, where, of course, it's not fought on British soil at all.
但当然，他们赢得了战争，所以你知道，它不可能算是一场多大的灾难。好吧，你觉得呢？你可能会把凡尔登当作一个典型例子，展现了法国人面对压倒性损失时拒绝投降的精神，但这件事也绝对配得上名列前茅。但你知道吗？我认为在英语世界中，法国对第一次世界大战的贡献通常被严重低估了，法国在一战中的重要性也被低估了。战争是在法国国土上进行的，法国人伤亡惨重。而像凡尔登这样的地方，那种全国动员、牺牲奉献的精神，我认为要远大于英国的任何情况，当然，英国的本土根本没有经历过战争。
Yeah, and which obviously has huge implications for France after the war, leading right the way up to the Second World War, but must also reflect the incredible insularity of British approaches to the war, I guess. And also, I guess, is drawing on traditions that were there in the early weeks of the war where the British are all complaining that the French are hopeless and useless. And the French, as we will see, are complaining that the British are refusing to do what they want them to do. So this sense of mutual contempt of these two allied forces, not very promising, really. No, no, not at all. Well, let's move slightly further north. So in Belgium, as we've heard, the Germans have taken Brussels, and now 600,000 men of the second and third German armies are basically sweeping south towards the French border. And in their way, near the town of Chalua is the French Fifth Army and the little British expeditionary force, which has now just got into Belgium.
Yeah, and which obviously has huge implications for France after the war, leading right the way up to the Second World War, but must also reflect the incredible insularity of British approaches to the war, I guess. And also, I guess, is drawing on traditions that were there in the early weeks of the war where the British are all complaining that the French are hopeless and useless. And the French, as we will see, are complaining that the British are refusing to do what they want them to do. So this sense of mutual contempt of these two allied forces, not very promising, really. No, no, not at all. Well, let's move slightly further north. So in Belgium, as we've heard, the Germans have taken Brussels, and now 600,000 men of the second and third German armies are basically sweeping south towards the French border. And in their way, near the town of Chalua is the French Fifth Army and the little British expeditionary force, which has now just got into Belgium.|||是的，这显然对战后法国有着巨大的影响，一直延续到第二次世界大战，但我想，这也反映了英国对战争看法的难以置信的狭隘。而且我想，这也借鉴了战争初期就存在的传统，当时英国人都在抱怨法国人无可救药、毫无用处。而正如我们将看到的，法国人则在抱怨英国人拒绝做他们希望英国人做的事。因此，这两种盟军部队之间相互蔑视的感觉，真的不是很有希望。不，不，一点也不。好吧，让我们稍微向北移动一点。因此在比利时，正如我们所听到的，德国人已经攻占了布鲁塞尔，现在德国第二集团军和第三集团军的六十万大军基本上正向南席卷法国边境。在他们前进的道路上，靠近沙勒罗瓦镇的是法国第五集团军和刚刚进入比利时的英国远征军小分队。
So the French and the British are outnumbered about two to one. And the French commander is a guy called Charles Longrazac. And he is a very interesting guy. He actually came from Guadalupe. And he's seen as a great sort of military intellectual. Now, his relationship with the British is absolutely atrocious. He knew Sir Henry Wilson. And he once said to Sir Henry Wilson, he said,
So the French and the British are outnumbered about two to one. And the French commander is a guy called Charles Longrazac. And he is a very interesting guy. He actually came from Guadalupe. And he's seen as a great sort of military intellectual. Now, his relationship with the British is absolutely atrocious. He knew Sir Henry Wilson. And he once said to Sir Henry Wilson, he said,|||因此，法军和英军在人数上处于二对一的劣势。法国指挥官是一个名叫查尔斯·朗扎克的人。他是一个非常有趣的人。他实际上来自瓜德罗普岛。他被视为某种伟大的军事知识分子。现在，他与英国人的关系简直糟透了。他认识亨利·威尔逊爵士。他曾对亨利·威尔逊爵士说，
there are only three phrases in English that anybody should ever learn. And they are beautiful woman. kiss me quick and beef steak and potatoes, but not all at once, presumably. I think you could have a brilliant holiday with those three words. And just to remind people, Henry Wilson speaks excellent French, doesn't he? Yes, exactly. Now, Laurentzac is a real Cassandra, as in he's right. He has been warning his fellow French commanders for weeks that the Germans are going to come
there are only three phrases in English that anybody should ever learn. And they are beautiful woman. kiss me quick and beef steak and potatoes, but not all at once, presumably. I think you could have a brilliant holiday with those three words. And just to remind people, Henry Wilson speaks excellent French, doesn't he? Yes, exactly. Now, Laurentzac is a real Cassandra, as in he's right. He has been warning his fellow French commanders for weeks that the Germans are going to come|||英语中只有三句话是任何人无论如何都应该学的。它们是：美丽的女人、快吻我、还有牛排配土豆，当然，我想不能同时享用。我想你可以用这三个词度过一个精彩的假期。顺便提醒大家一下，亨利·威尔逊的法语说得非常好，对吧？是的，完全正确。现在，朗扎克就像真正的卡珊德拉一样，也就是说他是对的。他数周来一直在警告他的法国同僚指挥官们，德国人将会
through Belgium and they're going to come through Belgium in far greater strength than anybody thinks. And basically nobody has listened to him because they just think he's a massive doomster and they, you know, who cares what this guy thinks? And a week before the Battle of the Frontiers, Longazek had gone to see Joffre and he had said, please don't send your troops into the death trap of the Ardennes.
through Belgium and they're going to come through Belgium in far greater strength than anybody thinks. And basically nobody has listened to him because they just think he's a massive doomster and they, you know, who cares what this guy thinks? And a week before the Battle of the Frontiers, Longazek had gone to see Joffre and he had said, please don't send your troops into the death trap of the Ardennes.|||穿过比利时，而且他们穿过比利时时的兵力将远超所有人的想象。基本上没有人听他的话，因为他们只觉得他是个散布末日论的大嘴巴，他们觉得，你知道的，谁在乎这家伙怎么想？在边境战役爆发前的一周，朗扎克曾去见霞飞，他对霞飞说，请不要把你的军队派往阿登森林的死亡陷阱。
That's his words. And Joffre had said, no way. Now, by the way, I forbid you to retreat when the Germans come at you. And Lorazac said, I left with death in my soul. So now, a week on from that, the 21st of August, Lorenzac realizes, geez, I was completely right, because he hears reports that the German
That's his words. And Joffre had said, no way. Now, by the way, I forbid you to retreat when the Germans come at you. And Lorazac said, I left with death in my soul. So now, a week on from that, the 21st of August, Lorenzac realizes, geez, I was completely right, because he hears reports that the German|||这是他的原话。霞飞则回答：没门。顺便说一句，当德国人向你发起进攻时，我禁止你撤退。朗扎克说：我带着灵魂深处的死亡痛苦离开了。所以现在，距离那件事一周后的8月21日，朗扎克意识到，天哪，我完全是对的，因为他听到报告说德国的
second and third armies are coming right at him. The Germans capture these bridges over the River Sambre. He tries to retake the bridges. He can't, the Germans can't be dislodged, and they keep coming. The next day is the 22nd of August. So this is the same day that Joffrosmann are being massacred in the Ardennes. Lorizak sends the 5th Army into the attack. He almost says, we've got to recapture these bridges. We've got to stop the Germans from getting across. It's a complete and utter disaster. So there's a British liaison officer who's watching who says they went into this salt with the utmost gallantry
second and third armies are coming right at him. The Germans capture these bridges over the River Sambre. He tries to retake the bridges. He can't, the Germans can't be dislodged, and they keep coming. The next day is the 22nd of August. So this is the same day that Joffrosmann are being massacred in the Ardennes. Lorizak sends the 5th Army into the attack. He almost says, we've got to recapture these bridges. We've got to stop the Germans from getting across. It's a complete and utter disaster. So there's a British liaison officer who's watching who says they went into this salt with the utmost gallantry|||第二和第三集团军正径直向他逼近。德国人占领了桑布尔河上的这些桥梁。他试图夺回这些桥梁。他办不到，德国人无法被驱逐，而且他们源源不断地涌来。第二天是8月22日。所以这正是霞飞的人马在阿登遭到大屠杀的同一天。朗扎克派遣第五集团军发起进攻。他几乎是说，我们必须夺回这些桥梁。我们必须阻止德国人过河。这简直是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。因此，有一名正在观战的英国联络官说，他们以极大的英勇精神投入到这次进攻中
as if at manoeuvres, beules blowing, drums beating, flags flying. They were like eager children, as gay as if it were the dawn of a holiday and they were going to march down the road to make a day of it at the local fair. And across the valley, German artillery, machine guns, the result is a complete and utter bloodbath. And Lorizak's army begins to break. So he holds out for another day. And then by the 23rd of August, he says, you know, sod my orders.
as if at manoeuvres, beules blowing, drums beating, flags flying. They were like eager children, as gay as if it were the dawn of a holiday and they were going to march down the road to make a day of it at the local fair. And across the valley, German artillery, machine guns, the result is a complete and utter bloodbath. And Lorizak's army begins to break. So he holds out for another day. And then by the 23rd of August, he says, you know, sod my orders.|||仿佛是在进行军事演习，号角吹响，战鼓擂动，彩旗飘扬。他们就像急切的孩子一样，高兴得就像假期的清晨，他们将沿着道路行进，去当地的集市上痛快玩上一天。而在山谷的对面，是德国的火炮和机枪，结果是一场彻头彻尾的血洗。朗扎克的军队开始崩溃。因此他再坚持了一天。然后到了8月23日，他说，你知道吗，去他的命令吧。
We just have to retreat now. The army is going to be destroyed. And he's right about that, isn't he? He's totally right. So he, in a way, his retreat enables in the long run the French army to hold the Germans off. He's really hard done by because, spoiler alert, he ends up being fired. But actually, he was right about everything. Anyway, his men are retreating.
We just have to retreat now. The army is going to be destroyed. And he's right about that, isn't he? He's totally right. So he, in a way, his retreat enables in the long run the French army to hold the Germans off. He's really hard done by because, spoiler alert, he ends up being fired. But actually, he was right about everything. Anyway, his men are retreating.|||我们现在必须撤退。军队就要被消灭了。关于这一点他说得对，不是吗？他完全正确。因此，从某种意义上说，他的撤退从长远来看使法国军队能够抵挡住德国人。他真的很冤枉，因为剧透一下，他最终被解雇了。但实际上，他每件事都是对的。不管怎样，他的部下正在撤退。
Now, the British are kind of adjoining them. And the British, of course, have been like drinking wine, kissing people at stations, you know. Mool and Frit and all that. Exactly. They've been a very brilliant time. Have they been told that the French are retreating? No. They haven't been told, A, that the French are retreating, or B, there are loads of Germans coming right at them.
Now, the British are kind of adjoining them. And the British, of course, have been like drinking wine, kissing people at stations, you know. Mool and Frit and all that. Exactly. They've been a very brilliant time. Have they been told that the French are retreating? No. They haven't been told, A, that the French are retreating, or B, there are loads of Germans coming right at them.|||现在，英国人正与他们相邻。而英国人呢，当然一直在喝酒、在车站跟人亲吻，你知道的。莫尔和弗里特之类的事。没错。他们度过了一段非常美好的时光。他们被告知法国人正在撤退吗？没有。他们没有被告知，A，法国人正在撤退，或者B，有大量的德国人正朝他们直奔而来。
So basically, they have no idea what's about to hit them. No. So by the evening of the 22nd of August, they have reached this little industrial town called Mons, which is about 20 miles west of Chalua, where Lorazac has been having his terrible sort of meltdown. Now, they think the Germans are still way ahead of them, and they have no idea how many Germans there are. But a few miles away in the darkness as night falls, the 160,000 men of Alexander von Klux German First Army are preparing. to strike. And Dominic, remind us how many men of the British Expeditionary Force are lying in their path? There are about 80,000 outnumbered two to one.
So basically, they have no idea what's about to hit them. No. So by the evening of the 22nd of August, they have reached this little industrial town called Mons, which is about 20 miles west of Chalua, where Lorazac has been having his terrible sort of meltdown. Now, they think the Germans are still way ahead of them, and they have no idea how many Germans there are. But a few miles away in the darkness as night falls, the 160,000 men of Alexander von Klux German First Army are preparing. to strike. And Dominic, remind us how many men of the British Expeditionary Force are lying in their path? There are about 80,000 outnumbered two to one.|||所以基本上，他们根本不知道有什么灾难要降临到他们头上。没有。因此，到8月22日傍晚，他们到达了一个名为蒙斯的工业小镇，该镇位于沙勒罗瓦以西约20英里处，朗扎克正是在那里经历了可怕的崩溃。现在，他们认为德国人还在他们前方很远的地方，而且他们根本不知道有多少德国人。但在几英里外的夜色渐浓中，亚历山大·冯·克卢克麾下德国第一集团军的16万大军正在准备发起进攻。多米尼克，提醒一下我们，在他们的必经之路上有多少名英国远征军士兵？大约有8万名，兵力处于二对一的劣势。
These are the kind of odds that the British enjoy. So unbelievable excitement. And we will find out what happens next after the break. Wendy's most important deal of the day has a fresh lineup. Pick any two breakfast items for $4. New four-piece French toast sticks, bacon or sausage wrap, biscuit or English muffin sandwiches, small hot coffee and more. Limited time only at participating Wendy's Taxes Extra. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History.
These are the kind of odds that the British enjoy. So unbelievable excitement. And we will find out what happens next after the break. Wendy's most important deal of the day has a fresh lineup. Pick any two breakfast items for $4. New four-piece French toast sticks, bacon or sausage wrap, biscuit or English muffin sandwiches, small hot coffee and more. Limited time only at participating Wendy's Taxes Extra. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History.|||这正是英国人喜欢的胜算。因此令人难以置信地兴奋。广告休息之后，我们将揭晓接下来会发生什么。温蒂汉堡当天的最重要优惠迎来全新阵容。任意挑选两款早餐只需4美元。全新的四片法式吐司条、培根或香肠卷、饼干或英式马芬三明治、小杯热咖啡等等。仅限参与活动的温蒂汉堡门店，税费另计。你好，欢迎回到《历史的剩余》。
It's the 22nd of August 1914. And for the last 10 days, the British Expeditionary Force, has been marching east through the fields of eastern France and Belgium. Following, I guess you could say, you know, they've crossed the channel in the manner that the English did under Edward III. Henry the 5th, when English armies loved fighting against overwhelming odds. So part of a continuum, you might say. And Dominant, we've been hearing from Aubrey Herbert, this Balliol man turned Tory MP,
It's the 22nd of August 1914. And for the last 10 days, the British Expeditionary Force, has been marching east through the fields of eastern France and Belgium. Following, I guess you could say, you know, they've crossed the channel in the manner that the English did under Edward III. Henry the 5th, when English armies loved fighting against overwhelming odds. So part of a continuum, you might say. And Dominant, we've been hearing from Aubrey Herbert, this Balliol man turned Tory MP,|||今天是1914年8月22日。在过去的10天里，英国远征军一直穿过法国东部和比利时的田野向东行军。追随者，我想你可以这么说，你知道的，他们以爱德华三世统治时期英国人那样的方式横渡了海峡。亨利五世时期，当时的英国军队酷爱在绝对劣势的兵力下作战。所以可以说是某种历史延续的一部分。多米尼克，我们一直听到奥布里·赫伯特的声音，这个贝利奥尔学院出身并转任保守党议员的人，
and we don't have that kind of person on Goldhanger podcast, do we? And he wrote, the people threw open their houses, their barns and their orchards. They could not have been kinder. Everywhere corn was offered for our horses and wine for ourselves, but there was a great fear underlying the quiet. So it's not total insouciance. There is a sense of foreboding. Oh, there definitely is. I think as they get to Mons, which they do that afternoon, when they get to Mons, there
and we don't have that kind of person on Goldhanger podcast, do we? And he wrote, the people threw open their houses, their barns and their orchards. They could not have been kinder. Everywhere corn was offered for our horses and wine for ourselves, but there was a great fear underlying the quiet. So it's not total insouciance. There is a sense of foreboding. Oh, there definitely is. I think as they get to Mons, which they do that afternoon, when they get to Mons, there|||我们在戈尔德汉杰播客上可没有这样的人，对吧？他写道：当地人向我们敞开了他们的房屋、谷仓和果园。他们再善良不过了。到处都有人为我们的战马提供谷物，为我们自己提供葡萄酒，但在平静的表面下却隐藏着巨大的恐惧。所以这并不是完全的无忧无虑。有一种不祥的预感。哦，绝对有。我想当他们到达蒙斯时——他们那天下午确实到了——当他们到达蒙斯时，
is this sense now, okay, the, you know, the big clash is coming. Something is up ahead. Now, they are, I mean, they've been marching for, what is it, 10 days or so. So they're footsore. They're burned by the sun. But they're pretty confident, I think. They know that they're excited, I think, rather than. really apprehensive. Their officers say that evening, okay, stop here. We will hold the canal.
is this sense now, okay, the, you know, the big clash is coming. Something is up ahead. Now, they are, I mean, they've been marching for, what is it, 10 days or so. So they're footsore. They're burned by the sun. But they're pretty confident, I think. They know that they're excited, I think, rather than. really apprehensive. Their officers say that evening, okay, stop here. We will hold the canal.|||这种感觉出现了：好吧，你知道的，大冲突要来了。前方有情况。现在，他们——我的意思是，他们已经行军了，大约10天左右。所以他们双脚酸痛。他们被太阳晒黑了。但我认为他们相当自信。我认为他们知道自己是兴奋的，而不是真正的忧虑。他们的军官那天晚上说：好吧，在这里停下。我们将坚守运河。
There's a canal that runs about 15 miles west towards the French border. This is where we'll stop. They know that there are some Germans ahead of them. But Sir John French, their hapless commander-in-chief, says, there are not many Germans. No, it'll be absolutely fine. They hear that afternoon and that evening the thunder of guns away to the east, and they don't know what it is. actually what it is, is L'Hazac's men being pushed back at Chalwa. So leaving them exposed. Exactly. Nine miles away now.
There's a canal that runs about 15 miles west towards the French border. This is where we'll stop. They know that there are some Germans ahead of them. But Sir John French, their hapless commander-in-chief, says, there are not many Germans. No, it'll be absolutely fine. They hear that afternoon and that evening the thunder of guns away to the east, and they don't know what it is. actually what it is, is L'Hazac's men being pushed back at Chalwa. So leaving them exposed. Exactly. Nine miles away now.|||有一条运河向西延伸约15英里，通往法国边境。我们就在这里停下。他们知道前方有一些德国人。但他们那位倒霉的总司令约翰·弗朗茨爵士却说：没有多少德国人。不，绝对没事的。那天下午和傍晚，他们听到远处的东方传来隆隆的炮声，但他们不知道那是什么。实际上那是什么呢，是朗扎克的人马在沙勒罗瓦被逼退。从而使他们暴露了出来。没错。现在就在9英里外。
So the British are now nine miles in front of the blooded and battered French army to their right. But Sir John doesn't know this. And air reconnaissance reports to him and says, there's a load of Germans up ahead. And Sir John French actually says, no, that can't be right. You must be mistaken. which is amazing, isn't it? Because the implication is that the whole British expeditionary force could be surrounded and wiped out. I mean, the odds are very high that this is going to be their fate. Right. Exactly. So late that night, he gets another message from Longozac. Lonerzac says, you know, I'm in terrible trouble to your right. Please wheel your army to the right and come and help us out. And Sir John French, this is very much his vibe. He says, no, we're absolutely fine where we are. I like, I like. our position where we are, actually. You look after yourself. And he goes to bed and he sleeps very soundly and nothing, he thinks nothing could possibly go wrong. But in the night, the centuries,
So the British are now nine miles in front of the blooded and battered French army to their right. But Sir John doesn't know this. And air reconnaissance reports to him and says, there's a load of Germans up ahead. And Sir John French actually says, no, that can't be right. You must be mistaken. which is amazing, isn't it? Because the implication is that the whole British expeditionary force could be surrounded and wiped out. I mean, the odds are very high that this is going to be their fate. Right. Exactly. So late that night, he gets another message from Longozac. Lonerzac says, you know, I'm in terrible trouble to your right. Please wheel your army to the right and come and help us out. And Sir John French, this is very much his vibe. He says, no, we're absolutely fine where we are. I like, I like. our position where we are, actually. You look after yourself. And he goes to bed and he sleeps very soundly and nothing, he thinks nothing could possibly go wrong. But in the night, the centuries,|||因此，英国人现在位于他们右侧那支历经血战、饱受摧残的法国军队前方9英里处。但约翰爵士并不知道这一点。空中侦察向他报告说，前方有大量的德国人。而约翰·弗朗茨爵士居然说：不，那不可能对。你一定弄错了。这真是令人匪夷所思，不是吗？因为这意味着整个英国远征军都可能被包围并歼灭。我的意思是，他们面临这种命运的几率非常高。对。确实如此。所以在那天深夜，他又收到了来自朗扎克的另一条消息。朗扎克说：你知道的，我在你右翼遇到了巨大的麻烦。请把你的军队向右转弯，来帮帮我们。而约翰·弗朗茨爵士，这非常符合他的风格。他说：不，我们呆在现在的地方挺好的。我其实很喜欢我们现在的这个位置。你自己照顾好自己吧。然后他去睡觉了，睡得非常香，他认为绝对不会出什么差错。但是在夜里，哨兵们——
the British sentries, can hear gunfire in the distance. And they're starting to get quite jittery now. Anyway, dawn breaks on the 23rd of August. So John, of course, is staying at a chateau, the Chateau des Arts. He's in great form when he wakes up. He says to his men, there probably are some Germans ahead. I think they're probably only got two divisions, which would be 40,000 men. And he says, it's nothing to worry about. He says, here's the plan. When the Germans come at you, I think you should do one of three things. You could advance and fight them.
the British sentries, can hear gunfire in the distance. And they're starting to get quite jittery now. Anyway, dawn breaks on the 23rd of August. So John, of course, is staying at a chateau, the Chateau des Arts. He's in great form when he wakes up. He says to his men, there probably are some Germans ahead. I think they're probably only got two divisions, which would be 40,000 men. And he says, it's nothing to worry about. He says, here's the plan. When the Germans come at you, I think you should do one of three things. You could advance and fight them.|||英国哨兵能够听到远处的枪声。他们现在开始变得相当紧张不安了。无论如何，8月23日的黎明破晓了。约翰爵士当然是住在城堡里，也就是德萨尔城堡。他醒来时状态极佳。他对部下说：前方可能确实有一些德国人。我想他们大概只有两个师，也就是40,000人。他还说：没什么好担心的。他说：计划是这样的。当德国人向你们进攻时，我认为你们应该做以下三件事之一。你可以向前推进并与他们战斗。
You could hold the line and stay where you are. Or you could retreat. Brilliant. That covers all the bases. And then, unbelievably, he says, I'm going to have a little tour. And he drives off for the rest of the day. Brilliant. Now, actually, of course, as we said, the approaching Germans are 160,000 men of Alexander
You could hold the line and stay where you are. Or you could retreat. Brilliant. That covers all the bases. And then, unbelievably, he says, I'm going to have a little tour. And he drives off for the rest of the day. Brilliant. Now, actually, of course, as we said, the approaching Germans are 160,000 men of Alexander|||你可以坚守阵线并留在原地。或者你可以撤退。太棒了。这面面俱到。然后，令人难以置信的是，他说：我要去兜个风。然后他开车离开，度过了剩余的一天。太棒了。现在，实际上，当然，正如我们所说，逼近的德国人是亚历山大麾下的16万大军——
of on Klux's first army. And at nine o'clock, they start this artillery bombardment. So there's kind of shells raining down on the British by the canal. And then at about nine o'clock, the Germans launched their first attacks on the bridges over the canal. So there's a bit of the canal called the Mons Salient that boulders out to the north. Now, for many of the younger British troops, this is their first experience of combat. And I'm delighted to report, Tom. Do we do well? They were very well trained. They're very well equipped. The Germans actually were so impressed by the British rate of fire. Because don't forget, rate of fire has always been a British thing. Think about Nelson's Navy. We're very good at firing. And the Germans are
of on Klux's first army. And at nine o'clock, they start this artillery bombardment. So there's kind of shells raining down on the British by the canal. And then at about nine o'clock, the Germans launched their first attacks on the bridges over the canal. So there's a bit of the canal called the Mons Salient that boulders out to the north. Now, for many of the younger British troops, this is their first experience of combat. And I'm delighted to report, Tom. Do we well? They were very well trained. They're very well equipped. The Germans actually were so impressed by the British rate of fire. Because don't forget, rate of fire has always been a British thing. Think about Nelson's Navy. We're very good at firing. And the Germans are|||冯·克卢克的第一集团军。九点钟，他们开始了炮击。因此运河旁的英国人头上犹如炮弹雨下。然后在大约九点钟，德国人对运河上的桥梁发动了第一波进攻。运河有一个向北凸出的部分被称为蒙斯突出部。现在，对于许多年轻的英国部队来说，这是他们第一次经历战斗。汤姆，我很高兴地向你汇报。我们表现得好吗？他们训练有素。他们的装备非常精良。德国人实际上对英国人的射击速度印象深刻。因为别忘了，射击速度一直是英国人的强项。想想纳尔逊的海军。我们非常擅长射击。而德国人则——
so impressed that they report back the British have machine guns, lots of machine guns, which we didn't. We're just as good as a machine. So that's nice. But there are so many Germans that in the hours that pass, they're fighting their way across this canal, across these bridges. And it's one of these battles where there are basically tremendous stories of sort of boys' own heroism on both sides. So the German, the top German, we should sort of doff our hats, the top German, who's a guy called Oscar Niemeyer. So Oscar Niemeier had been a gardener before the war and he swam across the canal. He got a boat. He got the boat back. He took men back and forth. And then he managed to open this swing bridge at Nimi that allowed loads of Germans to kind of pile across
so impressed that they report back the British have machine guns, lots of machine guns, which we didn't. We're just as good as a machine. So that's nice. But there are so many Germans that in the hours that pass, they're fighting their way across this canal, across these bridges. And it's one of these battles where there are basically tremendous stories of sort of boys' own heroism on both sides. So the German, the top German, we should sort of doff our hats, the top German, who's a guy called Oscar Niemeyer. So Oscar Niemeier had been a gardener before the war and he swam across the canal. He got a boat. He got the boat back. He took men back and forth. And then he managed to open this swing bridge at Nimi that allowed loads of Germans to kind of pile across|||印象深刻以至于他们报告说英国人有机枪，有很多机枪，而我们其实并没有。我们只是射速快得像机枪一样好。所以这挺好。但德国人实在太多了，在随后的几个小时里，他们一路战斗着穿过这条运河，穿过这些桥梁。这是一场双方基本上都涌现出大量男孩般英雄主义传奇故事的战役。因此，这位德国人，最高级别的德国人，我们应该脱帽致敬的最高级别的德国人，是一个名叫奥斯卡·尼迈耶的人。奥斯卡·尼迈耶在战前曾是一名园丁，他游过了运河。他弄到了一艘船。他又把船划了回来。他带着士兵们来回穿梭。然后他设法打开了尼米的那座旋转桥，让大量的德国人得以蜂拥过桥——
the bridge. And then he was hit and killed and he was kind of decorated after the war. And the German said what a great man he is. And he is a great man, I suppose, but not as great as Sid Godley. So Sidney Godley. We've had a lot of public school men in this episode. So it's nice to get somebody who perhaps represents the great majority of British soldiers. Sid Godley was a decorator's son from London, I think, who had worked as an ironmongery store before joining the Royal Fusiliers. He's part of this machine gun unit defending the railway bridge at Nimi. And the first machine gun crew were all killed. So that just leads. two blokes, Sid and his lieutenant who's called Morris Dees to take it over.
the bridge. And then he was hit and killed and he was kind of decorated after the war. And the German said what a great man he is. And he is a great man, I suppose, but not as great as Sid Godley. So Sidney Godley. We've had a lot of public school men in this episode. So it's nice to get somebody who perhaps represents the great majority of British soldiers. Sid Godley was a decorator's son from London, I think, who had worked as an ironmongery store before joining the Royal Fusiliers. He's part of this machine gun unit defending the railway bridge at Nimi. And the first machine gun crew were all killed. So that just leads. two blokes, Sid and his lieutenant who's called Morris Dees to take it over.|||桥。然后他中弹身亡，战后他还被追授了勋章。德国人说他是一个多么伟大的人啊。我想他确实是一个伟人，但没有西德·戈德利那么伟大。这就是西德尼·戈德利。我们在这一集里提到了很多公学出身的人。所以能有一个也许代表了绝大多数英国士兵的人出现，真是太好了。西德·戈德利我想是伦敦一个油漆匠的儿子，在加入皇家步兵团之前曾在一家五金店工作过。他是防守尼米铁路桥的这个机枪分队的一员。第一批机枪手全部阵亡了。所以这只剩下——两名男子，西德和他的排长莫里斯·迪斯接管了阵地。
Then Morris Dees is shot as well and the order comes to retreat for everybody else to retreat across the bridge but somebody has to cover them. And Sid Godley says, oh, I'll do it. And Dominic has a top historian of the First World War perhaps written about what then happens in amazing prose? In an amazingly moving and I think profound way, no? Shall I read it? Do read it. I'd love that. For two, hours, Sidney stayed at his post, his aching finger pressed on the trigger, giving his friends time to escape. All the time the German shells rained down, showering him with dirt and shrapnel, but he never faltered. One metal fragment flew into his back, another
Then Morris Dees is shot as well and the order comes to retreat for everybody else to retreat across the bridge but somebody has to cover them. And Sid Godley says, oh, I'll do it. And Dominic has a top historian of the First World War perhaps written about what then happens in amazing prose? In an amazingly moving and I think profound way, no? Shall I read it? Do read it. I'd love that. For two, hours, Sidney stayed at his post, his aching finger pressed on the trigger, giving his friends time to escape. All the time the German shells rained down, showering him with dirt and shrapnel, but he never faltered. One metal fragment flew into his back, another|||接着莫里斯·迪斯也中弹了，撤退的命令下达了，要求其他人全部撤退过桥，但必须有人掩护他们。西德·戈德利说：哦，我来。多米尼克，有没有一位一流的一次世界大战历史学家用精彩的散文写下了接下来发生的事情？以一种令人惊叹的感人且我认为深刻的方式，对吧？我来读一下吗？读吧。我非常乐意。西德尼在岗位上坚守了两个小时，他酸痛的手指扣在扳机上，为他的朋友们争取了逃跑的时间。德军的炮弹雨点般落下，泥土和弹片洒在他身上，但他从未动摇。一块金属碎片飞进他的背部，另一块——
into his shoulder, a bullet punched into his thigh. Then he felt a blinding pain in his head as another bullet thudded into his skull. Still, Sidney refused to give up, blazing away at the advancing grey ranks. And that is from your adventures in time on the First World War, a thrilling read, and godness. I mean, it makes you proud to be British, doesn't it, to hear that?
into his shoulder, a bullet punched into his thigh. Then he felt a blinding pain in his head as another bullet thudded into his skull. Still, Sidney refused to give up, blazing away at the advancing grey ranks. And that is from your adventures in time on the First World War, a thrilling read, and godness. It makes you proud to be British, doesn't isn't it, to hear that?|||射入他的肩膀，一颗子弹击穿了他的大腿。接着，当另一颗子弹击中他的头骨时，他感到头部一阵剧痛。尽管如此，西德尼仍然拒绝放弃，向逼近的灰色敌军队列疯狂开火。这段话摘自你的《穿越时空看一战》，这是一本惊心动魄的读物，天哪。听到这些，你会为自己是个英国人而感到自豪，对吧？
When I go to primary schools and people say, tell us an inspiring story and you can see the school head thinks, please, Lelope Rosa Parks. And actually, it's godly killing Germans. That's what the kids want. Anyway, he's captured by the German. he's taken to a POW camp near Berlin
When I go to primary schools and people say, tell us an inspiring story and you can see the school head thinks, please, Lelope Rosa Parks. And actually, it's godly killing Germans. That's what the kids want. Anyway, he's captured by the German. he's taken to a POW camp near Berlin|||当我去小学时，人们说，给我们讲个鼓舞人心的故事吧，你能看出校长心里想的是：求你了，讲讲罗莎·帕克斯吧。而实际上，是戈德利杀德国人。这才是孩子们想听的。无论如何，他被德国人俘虏了。他被带到了柏林附近的一个战俘营——
and then everybody behaves splendidly because he's given the Victoria Cross the Germans find out about it the people running the camp organised a special dinner with Sid as the guest of honour and the commandant came up and said well done and shook his hand
and then everybody behaves splendidly because he's given the Victoria Cross the Germans find out about it the people running the camp organised a special dinner with Sid as the guest of honour and the commandant came up and said well done and shook his hand|||然后所有人都表现得极其出色，因为他被授予了维多利亚十字勋章，德国人知道了这件事，营地的管理者们组织了一场特别的晚宴，邀请西德作为荣誉嘉宾，指挥官走过来对他说干得好并与他握手
and basically Oh lump in the throat so I mean huge kudos to Sydney Godley I mean he's done very well but it has to be said that actually the reason that the British get away is not Sid it's the fact that ghostly archers from the Battle of Agincourt come to their rescue at this point
and basically Oh lump in the throat so I mean huge kudos to Sydney Godley I mean he's done very well but it has to be said that actually the reason that the British get away is not Sid it's the fact that ghostly archers from the Battle of Agincourt come to their rescue at this point|||基本上——哦，真是令人哽咽，所以我的意思是，向西德尼·戈德利致以崇高的敬意，我的意思是他在那里做得非常好，但必须指出的是，实际上英国人能够脱身并不是因为西德，而是因为阿金库尔战役中的幽灵弓箭手在这个时候前来救援他们
and that's that's actually what happens so that's why I gave a little taster of the you know the 100 years war that that's that's actual historical fact isn't it Dominic yeah they're basically ghostly archers returned from the dead to help their British friends in their hour of need to help their descendants. And yeah, that this is a sign, obviously, that God was on Britain's side and that the spirit world was on Britain's side. And this becomes a massive story in the course of the war, the Angels and Mons, the idea of these sort of ghostly intervention.
and that's that's actually what happens so that's why I gave a little taster of the you know the 100 years war that that's that's actual historical fact isn't it Dominic yeah they're basically ghostly archers returned from the dead to help their British friends in their hour of need to help their descendants. And yeah, that this is a sign, obviously, that God was on Britain's side and that the spirit world was on Britain's side. And this becomes a massive story in the course of the war, the Angels and Mons, the idea of these sort of ghostly intervention.|||而这——这实际上就是发生的事情，所以这就是为什么我略微提及了百年战争，那是——那是真实的客观历史事实，对吧，多米尼克？是的，他们基本上是从死里复活的幽灵弓箭手，在英国朋友最需要的时刻回来帮助他们的后代。是的，这显然是一个迹象，表明上帝站在英国一边，精神世界也站在英国一边。这成为了战争期间的一个重大故事——蒙斯的天使，这种幽灵般干预的想法。
And Tom, do we have a special episode prepared for members of the Restis History Club on this very subject? We do, because obviously this is, as I said, this is the turning point of the entire First World War. to give it all the attention that it merits. And there will be a special bonus for club members on this coming out next week. And we'll be saying, you know, were they real? If they were, what were they? If they weren't, well, how on earth did people end up thinking all this? And it's an amazingly interesting story. Is there any way that just quickly, before we get back to the story,
And Tom, do we have a special episode prepared for members of the Restis History Club on this very subject? We do, because obviously this is, as I said, this is the turning point of the entire First World War. to give it all the attention that it merits. And there will be a special bonus for club members on this coming out next week. And we'll be saying, you know, were they real? If they were, what were they? If they weren't, well, how on earth did people end up thinking all this? And it's an amazingly interesting story. Is there any way that just quickly, before we get back to the story,|||汤姆，我们是否为《历史的剩余》俱乐部成员准备了关于这个主题的特别节目？我们确实准备了，因为显然正如我所说，这是整个第一次世界大战的转折点，为了给予它应有的所有关注。下周将为俱乐部会员推出关于此事的特别福利。我们会探讨，你知道的，它们是真的吗？如果是真的，它们是什么？如果不是真的，人们到底是怎么想出这一切的？这是一个极其有趣的故事。在我们回到正题之前，有没有什么快速的方法——
that people who want to hear that episode but are not members of the rest of history club, how could they, how could they get to hear it? There is Dominic. They could go to this website, and you just type in the rest is history.com and then you kind of click your mouse and it'll take you there and it's amazing. That's brilliant, Tom. And the great thing about all this is that nobody minds the narrative
that people who want to hear that episode but are not members of the rest of history club, how could they, how could they get to hear it? There is Dominic. They could go to this website, and you just type in the rest is history.com and then you kind of click your mouse and it'll take you there and it's amazing. That's brilliant, Tom. And the great thing about all this is that nobody minds the narrative|||那些想听那一集但又不是《历史的剩余》俱乐部成员的人，他们怎么才能、怎么才能听到呢？有的，多米尼克。他们可以访问这个网站，你只需输入therestishistory.com，然后点击鼠标，它就会把你带到那里，太棒了。太棒了，汤姆。这一切最棒的地方在于，没有人介意叙事
being interrupted for advertising in this way. Right, okay, so let's crack on. Theo's gesturing wildly in the background, flailing around. So actually, to get back to Earth, to the Battle of Mons, the British Expeditionary Force actually did do really well. They ended up being outnumbered more than three to one. They lost 1,600 men killed, wounded and taken prisoner,
being interrupted for advertising in this way. Right, okay, so let's crack on. Theo's gesturing wildly in the background, flailing around. So actually, to get back to Earth, to the Battle of Mons, the British Expeditionary Force actually did do really well. They ended up being outnumbered more than three to one. They lost 1,600 men killed, wounded and taken prisoner,|||以这种方式被广告打断。好吧，那么我们继续。西奥在背景里疯狂地做着手势，挥舞着手臂。所以实际上，回到现实，回到蒙斯战役，英国远征军其实表现得非常出色。他们最终在兵力上处于三比一以上的劣势。他们损失了1600名阵亡、受伤和被俘的士兵，
but by holding out, they had prevented von Kluck from outflanking and encircling the French. And the Germans were very impressed by how the British fought. So every single book on this battle mentions a quotation from a Brandenburg officer called Walter Bloom, whose battalion had suffered heavy losses. And he said, it was a bad defeat. There can be no gain saying it. We were badly beaten. And by the English, by the English that we'd laughed at a few hours before,
but by holding out, they had prevented von Kluck from outflanking and encircling the French. And the Germans were very impressed by how the British fought. So every single book on this battle mentions a quotation from a Brandenburg officer called Walter Bloom, whose battalion had suffered heavy losses. And he said, it was a bad defeat. There can be no gain saying it. We were badly beaten. And by the English, by the English that we'd laughed at a few hours before,|||但通过坚守，他们阻止了冯·克卢克对法军进行迂回包围。德国人对英国人的战斗表现印象深刻。因此，关于这场战役的每一本书都会引用一位名叫沃尔特·布卢姆的勃兰登堡军官的话，他的营伤亡惨重。他说：这是一场惨败。这是无可否认的。我们被狠狠地击败了。而且是被英国人，被我们几个小时前还在嘲笑的英国人，
What are they doing, laughing with the English? But the Germans aren't actually defeated, are they? Because the British do have to withdraw, because if they don't withdraw, then they would be cut off. Exactly. So they do have to withdraw. Now, Sir John French, right, who's gone on a nice drive that day, who's been so confident up to this point. At this point, he completely loses the plot. So having been madly overconfident before, he now sinks into total and utter gloom.
What are they doing, laughing with the English? But the Germans aren't actually defeated, are they? Because the British do have to withdraw, because if they don't withdraw, then they would be cut off. Exactly. So they do have to withdraw. Now, Sir John French, right, who's gone on a nice drive that day, who's been so confident up to this point. At this point, he completely loses the plot. So having been madly overconfident before, he now sinks into total and utter gloom.|||他们怎么跟英国人一起笑起来了？但德国人实际上并没有被击败，对吧？因为英国人确实不得不撤退，因为如果他们不撤退，他们就会被切断退路。没错。所以他们确实不得不撤退。现在，约翰·弗朗茨爵士——没错，他那天去兜了个风，在这之前一直信心满满。此时此刻，他彻底慌了神。因此，在此之前极度盲目自信的他，现在陷入了彻底的沮丧之中。
At one o'clock that night, he says, okay, like, we've lost. like keep retreating don't stop retreating actually let's go straight back to Amiens and if necessary we'll go from there to the ports and go home and this is the big French worry all the time isn't it that the British will kind of scuttle off and leave
At one o'clock that night, he says, okay, like, we've lost. like keep retreating don't stop retreating actually let's go straight back to Amiens and if necessary we'll go from there to the ports and go home and this is the big French worry all the time isn't it that the British will kind of scuttle off and leave|||那天夜里一点钟，他说：好吧，就像，我们输了。就像继续撤退，不要停止撤退，实际上我们直接回亚眠吧，如果有必要，我们从那里去港口然后回家。这一直是法国人最大的担忧，不是吗？担心英国人会溜之大吉并抛弃
them in the lurch well because by now the French too have realised that something has to change and they are now going back as well so the same day so this is the day after the Battle of Montes General Geoff goes to a meeting in Paris and he says to the war minister
them in the lurch well because by now the French too have realised that something has to change and they are now going back as well so the same day so this is the day after the Battle of Montes General Geoff goes to a meeting in Paris and he says to the war minister|||他们不管——好吧，因为此时法国人也意识到必须做出改变了，他们现在也在往回撤。所以就在同一天——也就是蒙斯战役的第二天，日尔夫将军（霞飞）去巴黎参加了一个会议，他对战争部长说：
France's strategy has completely and utterly failed. We must abandon all talk of attacking and we must retreat. Basically what we have to do now is to sort of hold on as long as we can and then we might be able to resume the offensive one day, but we'll have to rest and re-equip first. And Paris is the key. Yes. They've got to keep Paris from falling.
France's strategy has completely and utterly failed. We must abandon all talk of attacking and we must retreat. Basically what we have to do now is to sort of hold on as long as we can and then we might be able to resume the offensive one day, but we'll have to rest and re-equip first. And Paris is the key. Yes. They've got to keep Paris from falling.|||法国的战略彻底失败了。我们必须放弃所有关于进攻的谈论，我们必须撤退。基本上我们现在要做的是，尽可能长久地坚持下去，然后我们也许有一天能够恢复攻势，但我们必须先休整和重新装备。巴黎是关键。是的。他们必须防止巴黎陷落。
They've got to, exactly. So they're falling back towards Paris. So retreating for any army, it's obviously the most depressing thing you can do, but it's also the most dangerous thing you can do because the terror is that you will lose all your discipline and cohesion. And within a day of the retreat, so by about the 25th of August, at least one British officer is seriously worried that his units are going to fall apart,
They've got to, exactly. So they're falling back towards Paris. So retreating for any army, it's obviously the most depressing thing you can do, but it's also the most dangerous thing you can do because the terror is that you will lose all your discipline and cohesion. And within a day of the retreat, so by about the 25th of August, at least one British officer is seriously worried that his units are going to fall apart,|||他们必须这么做，完全正确。所以他们正在向巴黎方向撤退。因此，对任何军队来说，撤退显然是最令人沮丧的事情，但这也是最危险的事情，因为可怕的是你会失去所有的纪律和凝聚力。在撤退后的一天内，也就是大约8月25日左右，至少有一位英国军官非常担心他的部队会瓦解，
that the Germans are going to overwhelm them and destroy them. And this is another terrific character. He's called Sir Horace Smith Dorian. So he's the commander of number two corps, which is about half of the BEF. And he, I mean, he's had an amazing life, sort of flashman-esque life. He was one of a handful of men who had survived the terrible British defeat by the Zulus at his sandalwana in 1879. He'd been a comrade of great friend of the rest of his history, General Gordon. He fought against the Mardi in the Sudan in the last battle where the British ever wore red coats.
that the Germans are going to overwhelm them and destroy them. And this is another terrific character. He's called Sir Horace Smith Dorian. So he's the commander of number two corps, which is about half of the BEF. And he, I mean, he's had an amazing life, sort of flashman-esque life. He was one of a handful of men who had survived the terrible British defeat by the Zulus at his sandalwana in 1879. He'd been a comrade of great friend of the rest of his history, General Gordon. He fought against the Mardi in the Sudan in the last battle where the British ever wore red coats.|||担心德国人会压倒并消灭他们。这也是另一个了不起的人物。他叫霍勒斯·史密斯-多里安爵士。他是第二军团的指挥官，大约占英国远征军的一半。他——我的意思是，他有着传奇般的一生，有点像弗拉什曼式的生活。他是1879年在伊散德尔瓦纳被祖鲁人击败中幸存下来的少数英国人之一。他是《历史的剩余》的伟大朋友戈登将军的战友。他在苏丹与马赫迪作战，那是英国人最后一次身穿红军服参加的战役。
He fought to Ombudsman against the Khalifa. He was in the Boer War. What a life. And at Ombudsman had been commanded by General Kitchener. And Smith Dorian is a great friend of Kitchener, isn't he? And should we just mention at this point that Kitchener, this, you know, he's got the definitive British moustache. He's been appointed Secretary of State for War. And he hates French and French hates Kitchener.
He fought to Ombudsman against the Khalifa. He was in the Boer War. What a life. And at Ombudsman had been commanded by General Kitchener. And Smith Dorian is a great friend of Kitchener, isn't he? And should we just mention at this point that Kitchener, this, you know, he's got the definitive British moustache. He's been appointed Secretary of State for War. And he hates French and French hates Kitchener.|||他在恩图曼与哈利法作战。他参加过布尔战争。多么精彩的一生。在恩图曼曾受基钦纳将军指挥。史密斯-多里安是基钦纳的挚友，对吧？我们是否应该在此顺便提一下，基钦纳——这个，你知道的，他留着最具英国特色的胡子。他已被任命为陆军大臣。他讨厌弗朗茨（英国远征军司令约翰·弗朗茨），而弗朗茨也讨厌基钦纳。
So this is all adding to the mix. Because Kitchener had said, don't go to Belgium. Stay in Amiens. You know, if you go to Belgium, you'll just be forced back. and Kitchener had been right, and so obviously French hates him all the more for having been right. Exactly. And Smith Dorian has no time. It's John French. He despises him as a woman. He famously once said to him, too many whores around your headquarters field marshal.
So this is all adding to the mix. Because Kitchener had said, don't go to Belgium. Stay in Amiens. You know, if you go to Belgium, you'll just be forced back. and Kitchener had been right, and so obviously French hates him all the more for having been right. Exactly. And Smith Dorian has no time. It's John French. He despises him as a woman. He famously once said to him, too many whores around your headquarters field marshal.|||所以这一切都交织在了一起。因为基钦纳曾说过：不要去比利时。留在亚眠。你知道的，如果你去比利时，你只会部退回。而基钦纳当时是对的，所以很显然，弗朗茨因为基钦纳说对了而更加痛恨他。没错。史密斯-多里安根本瞧不起约翰·弗朗茨。他鄙视他像个女人。他曾有一句名言对他说：元帅阁下，你的指挥部周围有太多的妓女。
Basically, it's all about French's mistresses. And actually, before the war, Smith Dorian was invited to speak to, of course, the public school officer's training corps. And he said to them, war should be avoided at all costs. War would solve nothing. The whole of Europe would be reduced to ruin. And his public school audience were appalled by this, absolutely appalled and complained afterwards. But, of course, he was quite, he was right. Anyway, late on the 25th of August, Smith-Dorien's men reached a place called Le Cateau, which is just inside the French border.
Basically, it's all about French's mistresses. And actually, before the war, Smith Dorian was invited to speak to, of course, the public school officer's training corps. And he said to them, war should be avoided at all costs. War would solve nothing. The whole of Europe would be reduced to ruin. And his public school audience were appalled by this, absolutely appalled and complained afterwards. But, of course, he was quite, he was right. Anyway, late on the 25th of August, Smith-Dorien's men reached a place called Le Cateau, which is just inside the French border.|||基本上，全都是关于弗朗茨的情妇。事实上，在战前，史密斯-多里安曾应邀向公学军官训练团发表演讲。他对他们说：战争应该不惜一切代价避免。战争解决不了任何问题。整个欧洲都将化为废墟。他的公学听众对此感到震惊，绝对震惊，并在事后提出了抱怨。但是，当然，他完全是正确的。无论如何，在8月25日深夜，史密斯-多里安的部下到达了一个名为勒卡托的地方，该地恰好位于法国边境以内。
The home of Matisse. No way, really. Good fact. Very good fact. They're exhausted. They're hungry. They're really miserable. And he thinks, we can't go on.
The home of Matisse. No way, really. Good fact. Very good fact. They're exhausted. They're hungry. They're really miserable. And he thinks, we can't go on.|||马蒂斯的故乡。不会吧，真的吗？好事实。非常好的事实。他们精疲力竭。他们饥肠辘辘。他们真的很痛苦。他想，我们不能再这样下去了。
You know, if we try to keep retreating, the Germans will overtake us and destroy us. And overnight, he consulted his senior officers. One of the key voices is a man called Edmund Allenby, who goes on to be the conqueror of Jerusalem and of Damascus. And Alan B says, my horsemen, my cavalry, can't go on. The horses can't go on. Basically, either we stand on fire here, or the Germans will overtake us. And there's a silence, and then Smith Dorian says, of course,
You know, if we try to keep retreating, the Germans will overtake us and destroy us. And overnight, he consulted his senior officers. One of the key voices is a man called Edmund Allenby, who goes on to be the conqueror of Jerusalem and of Damascus. And Alan B says, my horsemen, my cavalry, can't go on. The horses can't go on. Basically, either we stand on fire here, or the Germans will overtake us. And there's a silence, and then Smith Dorian says, of course,|||你知道的，如果我们继续撤退，德国人会赶上并消灭我们。夜里，他咨询了高级军官。其中一个关键的声音是一个名叫埃德蒙·艾伦比的人，他后来成为了耶路撒冷和大马士革的征服者。艾伦比说：我的骑兵，我的骑兵坚持不下去了。马匹坚持不下去了。基本上，要么我们在这里坚守并开火，要么德国人会追上我们。现场一片寂静，然后史密斯-多里安说：当然，
very well, gentlemen, we shall fight. Now, there's a comic element to this. Most of the other British officers are kind of a state. in a funk. So of five o'clock in the morning, the news comes that Smith Dorian wants to fight. And the British chief of staff, Sir Archibald Murray, who's with the kind of French's headquarters, he hears this and he has a fainting fit and collapses at the thought of Smith Dorian wanting to fight. And somebody calls for a doctor, and another man there, who of course is called Fido Childs,
very well, gentlemen, we shall fight. Now, there's a comic element to this. Most of the other British officers are kind of a state. in a funk. So at five o'clock in the morning, the news comes that Smith Dorian wants to fight. And the British chief of staff, Sir Archibald Murray, who's with the kind of French's headquarters, he hears this and he has a fainting fit and collapses at the thought of Smith Dorian wanting to fight. And somebody calls for a doctor, and another man there, who of course is called Fido Childs,|||很好，先生们，我们战斗。现在，这里有一个滑稽的元素。其他大多数英国军官都有点状态不佳，处于恐慌之中。因此，在早上五点钟，传来了史密斯-多里安想要战斗的消息。英国总参谋长阿奇博尔德·默里爵士（当时在弗朗茨的指挥部）听到这个消息后，一想到史密斯-多里安想打仗，就当场晕厥并瘫倒在地。有人叫医生，现场另一个人——当然名叫菲多·柴尔兹——
shouts out, don't call a doctor. I have a pint of champagne. and pours this pint of champagne into Sir Archibald Murray to revive him. This is a tremendous behaviour. So that's been going on overnight. Morning comes, Sir John French goes off to talk to Joffre, and they meet in this darkened room. Obviously, neither of them speaks the other's language,
shouts out, don't call a doctor. I have a pint of champagne. and pours this pint of champagne into Sir Archibald Murray to revive him. This is a tremendous behaviour. So that's been going on overnight. Morning comes, Sir John French goes off to talk to Joffre, and they meet in this darkened room. Obviously, neither of them speaks the other's language,|||大喊道：别叫医生。我有一品脱香槟。然后把这一品脱香槟灌进阿奇博尔德·默里爵士嘴里把他救醒。这举动真是太棒了。所以这一切在夜里一直在进行。清晨来临，约翰·弗朗茨爵士去和霞飞谈话，他们在暗室里会面。很显然，他们俩谁也不会对方的语言，
so everything has to be translated, so it takes a week for the meetings that happen. Jophe says, I think you should counter-attack. French says, no, no, no, we're going to keep retreating. And the mood is completely funereal. So the liaison officer was called Edward Spears said, everyone's spoken in an undertone as if there were a corpse in the next room. The sense of doom was as evident as when a jury is about to return a verdict of guilty on a capital charge.
so everything has to be translated, so it takes a week for the meetings that happen. Jophe says, I think you should counter-attack. French says, no, no, no, we're going to keep retreating. And the mood is completely funereal. So the liaison officer was called Edward Spears said, everyone's spoken in an undertone as if there were a corpse in the next room. The sense of doom was as evident as when a jury is about to return a verdict of guilty on a capital charge.|||所以所有事情都必须翻译，因此会面花了一个星期的时间。霞飞说：我认为你应该反击。弗朗茨说：不，不，不，我们要继续撤退。气氛完全就像办丧事一样。因此名叫爱德华·斯皮尔斯的联络官说：每个人都压低声音说话，就像隔壁房间里停着一具尸体一样。末日降临的感觉就像陪审团即将对死刑指控作出有罪判决时一样明显。
I mean, who's right there? Presumably French is right. French is actually right, yeah. Geoffrey's mad to think about trying to attack. I mean, Smith Dorian is not trying to attack. He's just trying to kind of hold the – stop here, hold the Germans off for a bit, hold the line, and then we can carry on retreating. And this is what he does at La Cateau. And Le Cato is probably the last Napoleonic battle in history, maybe.
I mean, who's right there? Presumably French is right. French is actually right, yeah. Geoffrey's mad to think about trying to attack. I mean, Smith Dorian is not trying to attack. He's just trying to kind of hold the – stop here, hold the Germans off for a bit, hold the line, and then we can carry on retreating. And this is what he does at Le Cateau. And Le Cato is probably the last Napoleonic battle in history, maybe.|||我的意思是，谁是对的？大概弗朗茨是对的。弗朗茨其实是对的，是的。霞飞想尝试进攻简直是疯了。我的意思是，史密斯-多里安并不是在试图进攻。他只是想——在这里停下，把德国人挡住一会儿，坚守防线，然后我们就可以继续撤退了。这就是他在勒卡托所做的事情。勒卡托也许是历史上最后一场拿破仑式的战役了。
know. So there are columns of troops. There are people on horseback. There's kind of horse drawn artillery. Yeah, Dominic, just to say, just to say, because we've talked about horses quite a lot, this is a terrible time to be a horse, isn't it? Yes. Because they're all kinds of lunatic cavalry charges where horses just get wiped out. The French and the Germans both are very given to flogging their horses so that they just collapse. So anyone who's read the Michael Mopperga book or seen the drama of War Horse, I mean, it's based on horrendous cruelty to horses. And we should remember them as well as all the men who die in this conflict. So actually in this battle, the British fight incredibly well.
know. So there are columns of troops. There are people on horseback. There's kind of horse drawn artillery. Yeah, Dominic, just to say, just to say, because we've talked about horses quite a lot, this is a terrible time to be a horse, isn't it? Yes. Because they're all kinds of lunatic cavalry charges where horses just get wiped out. The French and the Germans both are very given to flogging their horses so that they just collapse. So anyone who's read the Michael Mopperga book or seen the drama of War Horse, I mean, it's based on horrendous cruelty to horses. And we should remember them as well as all the men who die in this conflict. So actually in this battle, the British fight incredibly well.|||你知道的。所以有部队纵队。有骑马的人。有某种马匹拉动的火炮。是的，多米尼克，顺便说一句，因为我们谈论了很多关于马的事情，对一匹马来说，这是个糟糕的时代，对吧？是的。因为有各种各样疯狂的骑兵冲锋，马匹直接被消灭。法德双方都非常喜欢鞭打马匹，以至于它们直接累垮。所以任何读过迈克尔·莫波格的书或看过《战马》戏剧的人都知道，我的意思是，它是基于对马匹的可怕残忍。我们应该记住它们，正如记住在这场冲突中死去的所有人一样。所以在实际上这场战役中，英国人打得极其出色。
They're holding out against overwhelming odds. they all behave splendidly. They have to retreat eventually and they have to get their guns out under fire so that means men on horses getting them out. Three men get Victoria crosses, a guy called Douglas Reynolds, who's a captain, and two drivers called Frederick Luke
They're holding out against overwhelming odds. they all behave splendidly. They have to retreat eventually and they have to get their guns out under fire so that means men on horses getting them out. Three men get Victoria crosses, a guy called Douglas Reynolds, who's a captain, and two drivers called Frederick Luke|||他们在绝对劣势下坚守。他们都表现得极其出色。他们最终不得不撤退，并且他们必须在炮火下将火炮运出来，这意味着要靠骑马的人把它们弄出来。三人获得了维多利亚十字勋章，一个名叫道格拉斯·雷诺兹的船长，以及两名驾驶员——弗雷德里克·卢克
and the excellently named Job Drain, who's 18. And there's actually a statue of Job Drain in Barking. Is there? Yeah, there is. You can Google it. Oh, wonderful. He's obviously a tremendous fellow.
and the excellently named Job Drain, who's 18. And there's actually a statue of Job Drain in Barking. Is there? Yeah, there is. You can Google it. Oh, wonderful. He's obviously a tremendous fellow.|||还有一个名字起得极好的、18岁的乔布·德雷恩。在巴金实际上还有一座乔布·德雷恩的雕像。真的吗？是的，有的。你可以在谷歌上查到。哦，太棒了。他显然是个了不起的家伙。
So, at Le Cato, the British lost more men than they lost on the first day of D-Day, would you believe? Good news. Now, it's a German victory. If you look on Wikipedia, Wikipedia says it's a German victory. But is it? Because actually the British have done two things. First of all, Smith Doran has given the rest of the British expeditionary force time to get away. And the Germans are now never going to catch up with them.
So, at Le Cato, the British lost more men than they lost on the first day of D-Day, would you believe? Good news. Now, it's a German victory. If you look on Wikipedia, Wikipedia says it's a German victory. But is it? Because actually the British have done two things. First of all, Smith Doran has given the rest of the British expeditionary force time to get away. And the Germans are now never going to catch up with them.|||因此，在勒卡托，英国人损失的人数比诺曼底登陆第一天损失的人数还要多，你敢相信吗？好消息。现在，这是一场德国人的胜利。如果你看维基百科，维基百科说这是一场德军的胜利。但真的是这样吗？因为实际上英国人做了两件事。首先，史密斯-多里安为英国远征军的其余部队争取了逃跑的时间。德国人现在再也追不上他们了。
And secondly, every day the Germans lose is vital to them. They had six weeks. They're already in week three. So every day the British delay them or the French delayed them makes it much harder for Malka's plan to work. So actually a lot of military historians say, sure, the British are going backwards and it looks like a German victory.
And secondly, every day the Germans lose is vital to them. They had six weeks. They're already in week three. So every day the British delay them or the French delayed them makes it much harder for Malka's plan to work. So actually a lot of military historians say, sure, the British are going backwards and it looks like a German victory.|||其次，德国人失去的每一天对他们来说都至关重要。他们有六周时间。他们已经进入第三周了。因此，英国人或法国人拖延他们的每一天，都会使小毛奇的计划更加难以奏效。所以实际上许多军事历史学家说，当然，英国人在后退，这看起来像是德国人的胜利。
But strategically, in the sort of long-term picture, it's kind of a win for the B.EF. A victory for British pluck. Hurrah. Well, anyway, now the Great Retreat is on. So, you know, Smith Dorian, when he described the Great Retreat, said, oh, it's absolutely splendid. Everyone was like walking away from a race meeting.
But strategically, in the sort of long-term picture, it's kind of a win for the B.EF. A victory for British pluck. Hurrah. Well, anyway, now the Great Retreat is on. So, you know, Smith Dorian, when he describe the Great Retreat, said, oh, it's absolutely splendid. Everyone was like walking away from a race meeting.|||但从战略上讲，从长远的角度来看，这对英国远征军来说算是一种胜利。这是英国勇气的胜利。万岁。好吧，不管怎样，现在大撤退开始了。所以，你知道的，史密斯-多里安在描述大撤退时说，哦，这绝对太棒了。每个人都像从赛马会散场一样。
Everyone's smoking their pipes and chatting. This is like complete romantic self-delusion. Actually, they're marching 200 miles in 11 days. They're sleeping about four hours a night. They are absolutely shattered. The roads are strewn with abandoned wagons, with dead horses. They're kind of basically sleepwalking by the end, aren't they? Kept awake by the pain from their blisters.
Everyone's smoking their pipes and chatting. This is like complete romantic self-delusion. Actually, they're marching 200 miles in 11 days. They're sleeping about four hours a night. They are absolutely shattered. The roads are strewn with abandoned wagons, with dead horses. They're kind of basically sleepwalking by the end, aren't they? Kept awake by the pain from their blisters.|||每个人都在抽着烟斗聊天。这完全是浪漫主义的自我欺骗。实际上，他们在11天内行军200英里。他们一晚大约只睡四个小时。他们已经彻底崩溃了。道路上到处都是被遗弃的马车和死去的马匹。到最后他们基本上是在梦游，不是吗？全靠脚上水泡带来的疼痛保持清醒。
They're really footsore. They're passing refugees. People who had cheered them. as they went one way, and now are glaring at them as they go the other, because they basically feel they're abandoning them. Morale is terrible. They've all got terrible diarrhea. They're all massively sunburnt. None of them have any idea where they are. There's no sense of a plan. Gunner Sergeant William Edgington on the 26th. He says, we're all feeling very much the want of sleep, no rations, all very much depressed owing to the total absence of any information.
They're really footsore. They're passing refugees. People who had cheered them. as they went one way, and now are glaring at them as they go the other, because they basically feel they're abandoning them. Morale is terrible. They've all got terrible diarrhea. They're all massively sunburnt. None of them have any idea where they are. There's no sense of a plan. Gunner Sergeant William Edgington on the 26th. He says, we're all feeling very much the want of sleep, no rations, all very much depressed owing to the total absence of any information.|||他们双脚酸痛。他们经过难民身边。那些曾经为他们欢呼的人——当他们朝一个方向前进时，现在却怒视着他们朝另一个方向撤退，因为他们基本上觉得英国人在抛弃他们。士气糟透了。他们都得了严重的腹泻。他们都严重晒伤。他们谁也不知道自己在哪里。没有任何计划的概念。炮手班长威廉·埃基顿在26日说道：由于完全缺乏任何信息，我们所有人都感到极度缺觉，没有口粮，情绪都非常低落。
We appear to be simply driven blindly back. And Dominic, do they blame their own inadequacies? Or do they blame the French? Of course they blame the French. Of course they blame the French. Captain James Harbour. The damned French army never appears at all. There's been a bad strategy somewhere.
We appear to be simply driven blindly back. And Dominic, do they blame their own inadequacies? Or do they blame the French? Of course they blame the French. Of course they blame the French. Captain James Harbour. The damned French army never appears at all. There's been a bad strategy somewhere.|||我们看起来就像是被盲目地赶了回来。多米尼克，他们是在怪自己无能呢？还是在怪法国人？他们当然怪法国人。他们当然怪法国人。詹姆斯·哈伯上尉。该死的法国军队根本就没出现过。某个地方制定了糟糕的战略。
Grenadier, Guy, Harcourt, Vernon. Personally, I don't believe the French are properly mobilised. Whatever happens, the British army has done its duty. For the last week we've been fighting alone, I somebody can't believe in these Frenchmen. Basically, they really wanted to have been fighting the French. They're disappointed that they're not. And when it goes wrong, they blame
Grenadier, Guy, Harcourt, Vernon. Personally, I don't believe the French are properly mobilised. Whatever happens, the British army has done its duty. For the last week we've been fighting alone, I somebody can't believe in these Frenchmen. Basically, they really wanted to have been fighting the French. They're disappointed that they're not. And when it goes wrong, they blame|||掷弹兵盖伊·哈考特·弗农。就我个人而言，我不相信法国人已经进行了适当的动员。无论发生什么，英国军队都尽到了自己的职责。在过去的一周里，我们一直在孤军奋战，我简直无法信任这些法国人。基本上，他们真的很想跟法国人打一仗。他们对没能打成感到很失望。而当事情出错时，他们就会怪罪
the French instead. So now Sir John French, ironically, of course, doesn't like the French. He's now lost 15,000 men one way or another, which is tiny compared with the French losses. But if you've only got 80,000 men, you can't keep losing 15,000 a week and you went up an army left. And he writes to Joff at the end of August, and he says, we're not going to be in the front line. You know, don't expect to see us in the front line anytime soon. We're going to have to rest for at least 10 days. And in the same day, in his diary, he says, I have decided to retire behind the Sen to the west of Paris in the neighbourhood of Saint-Germain. Now, this is an incredible moment.
the French instead. So now Sir John French, ironically, of course, doesn't like the French. He's now lost 15,000 men one way or another, which is tiny compared with the French losses. But if you've only got 80,000 men, you can't keep losing 15,000 a week and you went up an army left. And he writes to Joff at the end of August, and he says, we're not going to be in the front line. You know, don't expect to see us in the front line anytime soon. We're going to have to rest for at least 10 days. And in the same day, in his diary, he says, I have decided to retire behind the Sen to the west of Paris in the neighbourhood of Saint-Germain. Now, this is an incredible moment.|||法国人。因此，现在约翰·弗朗茨爵士，具有讽刺意味的是，他当然不喜欢法国人。他现在通过各种方式已经损失了15,000人，与法军的损失相比，这微不足道。但如果你只有8万军队，你就不能每周损失1.5万人，否则你最后连军队都没了。他在8月底写信给霞飞，说：我们不会再待在前线了。你知道的，不要指望很快能在前线看到我们。我们至少得休整10天。就在同一天，他在日记中写道：我已决定撤退到巴黎以西塞纳河后方圣日耳曼附近。现在，这是一个令人难以置信的时刻。
Sir John French is talking about pulling the British army back behind Paris, effectively abandoning Paris to the Germans. And the next day, he sends a telegram to London, and he says, I'm washing my hands now of collaboration with the French. I don't see why I should again be called upon to run the risk of absolute disaster in order a second time to save them. So Max Hastings calls Sir John French a poltroon. Do you think that's, would you agree with that?
Sir John French is talking about pulling the British army back behind Paris, effectively abandoning Paris to the Germans. And the next day, he sends a telegram to London, and he says, I'm washing my hands now of collaboration with the French. I don't see why I should again be called upon to run the risk of absolute disaster in order a second time to save them. So Max Hastings calls Sir John French a poltroon. Do you think that's, would you agree with that?|||约翰·弗朗茨爵士在谈论将英国军队撤回巴黎背后，实际上是将巴黎拱手让给德国人。第二天，他向伦敦发了一封电报，说：我现在要洗手不干了，不再与法国人合作。我看不出我为什么还要再次被要求冒着彻底灾难的风险去第二次拯救他们。因此，马克斯·黑斯廷斯称约翰·弗朗茨爵士为懦夫。你认为——你同意这一点吗？
Of course he does. I think he is a bit of a poultry, to be honest with you. I mean, personally, I'd have been one of those people who said, don't send an army at all. Let the French look after themselves. Let's just rely on our splendid navy. But once you've gone there. I think once you've gone there, you've got to make an effort. You can't just go, dip your toes in the water and then say, okay, fine, I'm out of here.
Of course he does. I think he is a bit of a poultry, to be honest with you. I mean, personally, I'd have been one of those people who said, don't send an army at all. Let the French look after themselves. Let's just rely on our splendid navy. But once you've gone there. I think once you've gone there, you've got to make an effort. You can't just go, dip your toes in the water and then say, okay, fine, I'm out of here.|||当然同意。老实说，我认为他确实有点像个懦夫。我的意思是，就我个人而言，我会是那种说根本不要派军队的人。让法国人自己照顾自己。我们只需依靠我们辉煌的海军。但既然你已经去了那里。我认为既然你已经去了那里，你就必须付出努力。你不能只是去把脚伸进水里试探一下，然后就说：好吧，好了，我撤了。
Because the angels of remandes haven't appeared to allow him to scuttle off back to Dover. No, for nothing, precisely. Now, so the question now is, and we will pick this up in the next episode, What does London think? I'm happy to say that the great friend of the rest of his history, Herbert Henry Asquith, has been managing the war at admirable unconcern and general insoucients. So while everybody's been fighting, Asquith, Asquith, he's still been having country house weekends. So he spent one weekend, he went down to Kent.
Because the angels of remandes haven't appeared to allow him to scuttle off back to Dover. No, for nothing, precisely. Now, so the question now is, and we will pick this up in the next episode, What does London think? I'm happy to say that the great friend of the rest of his history, Herbert Henry Asquith, has been managing the war at admirable unconcern and general insoucients. So while everybody's been fighting, Asquith, Asquith, he's still been having country house weekends. So he spent one weekend, he went down to Kent.|||因为蒙斯的天使并没有显灵来允许他溜回多佛。不，确实没有，确切地说。现在，所以问题来了，我们将在下一集中继续探讨这个问题：伦敦是怎么想的？我很高兴地说，《历史的剩余》的伟大朋友赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯一直以令人钦佩的漠不关心和普遍的无忧无虑态度在管理着战争。所以当每个人都在战斗时，阿斯奎斯——阿斯奎斯他依然在过着乡间别墅周末。因此，他曾在一个周末去了肯特郡。
On the way, the man in charge of running the war noticed another driver had broken down. And he gave him a lift to the garage. Then on the way back, he saw some children from South London who'd been a holiday in Margate. And he said, oh, would you like me to give you a lift back to London? He gave them a lift as well. And then when he's actually doing any work, to quote Max Hastings, again. Ask with treated vital strategic issues, as
On the way, the man in charge of running the war noticed another driver had broken down. And he gave him a lift to the garage. Then on the way back, he saw some children from South London who'd been a holiday in Margate. And he said, oh, would you like me to give you a lift back to London? He gave them a lift as well. And then when he's actually doing any work, to quote Max Hastings, again. Ask with treated vital strategic issues, as|||在路上，负责领导战争的人注意到另一名司机的车抛锚了。他顺便捎了他一程去修理厂。然后在回来的路上，他看到了一些来自伦敦南部、在马盖特度假的孩子。他说：哦，你们想让我捎你们回伦敦吗？他也捎了他们一程。然后当他真正在做任何工作时，再次引用马克斯·黑斯廷斯的话。阿斯奎斯对待至关重要的战略问题，就像
if we were discussing the tiresome inability of some guests to attend a garden party. Now, the cabinet have been discussing, are they going to pull out the British expeditionary force via Dunkirk? But so far, they've said no.
if we were discussing the tiresome inability of some guests to attend a garden party. Now, the cabinet have been discussing, are they going to pull out the British expeditionary force via Dunkirk? But so far, they've said no.|||我们在讨论某些客人无法参加花园派对的令人讨厌的无能一样。现在，内阁一直在讨论，他们是否要通过敦刻尔克撤出英国远征军？但到目前为止，他们的回答是否定的。
And now that Sir John French has sent this message, they have a crucial decision to make. They have his telegram. Are they going to let him wash his hands of the whole campaign? So we'll pick up, we'll find out what happens in the next episode. But while they are deliberating 31st of August, the news is at last filtering through to the British public. So wartime censorship means that no one knows about this until now. There have been little hints. People writing in
既然约翰·弗朗西斯爵士已经发出了这条消息，他们面临着一个至关重要的决定。他们收到了他的电报。他们要让他置身事外于整个战役吗？所以我们将在下一集中了解接下来发生的事情。但在他们商议的8月31日，消息终于传到了英国公众耳中。战时审查制度意味着直到现在还没有人知道这件事。有一些小暗示。人们在日记中写道...
their diaries saying, I'm hearing reports of thousands of casualties, all of this. On the 29th, the Times had said, for the first time, the situation in France is very grave. And then on the 31st, the same day that Sir John French's telegram reaches London, the Times published a special edition with a report by its war correspondent Arthur Moore. And he wrote in this, this is a bombshell for the British public. It's important that the nation should now realize certain things, bitter truths, but we can face them. We have to cut our losses, take stock, set our teeth. To sum up, the first great German effort has succeeded. We have to face the fact, the British expeditionary force, which bore the great weight of the blow, has suffered terrible losses and requires
日记里写着，我听到关于数千人伤亡的报告，诸如此类。在29日，《泰晤士报》首次表示，法国的局势非常严峻。然后在31日，也就是约翰·弗朗西斯爵士的电报到达伦敦的同一天，《泰晤士报》出版了一期特别版，其中包含其战地记者阿瑟·穆尔的报道。他在文章中写道，这对英国公众来说是一个重磅炸弹。国家现在应该意识到某些事情，这是苦涩的真相，但我们可以面对。我们必须及时止损，盘点现状，咬紧牙关。总而言之，德国人的第一次重大努力已经成功。我们必须面对这个事实，承受了打击巨大分量的英国远征军遭受了惨重的损失，并需要
immediate and immense reinforcement. Domina, just to mention, this is the report that plays a crucial role in inspiring the story of the Angels of Mons. Oh, that's interesting. Right. Well, if you think the mood is bleak in London, it is even worse in Paris. The French capital, when the war had been declared, the mood had been one of great confidence. They'd looked forward to regaining Alsace and Lorraine.
多米娜，顺便提一下，正是这份报道在激发“蒙斯天使”的故事中起到了至关重要的作用。哦，这很有趣。没错。好吧，如果你认为伦敦的心情很黯淡，巴黎的形势就更糟了。法国首都，当战争宣战时，人们的情绪充满了极大的信心。他们期盼着重新夺回阿尔萨斯和洛林。
But now Paris is a city at bay. On the 28th of August, for the first time the French government issued a statement and they said, we can confirm there is fighting deep inside France from the Somme to the Vosges. And when they said that, the public were stunned. They thought the fighting was all in Belgium. They couldn't believe it when the French government said, it's actually deep inside France. And then two days later, the first German monoplane flew. over Paris and dropped five little bombs on Paris.
但现在的巴黎是一座陷入绝境的城市。8月28日，法国政府首次发表声明称，我们可以确认从索姆河到孚日山脉的法国腹地深处正在发生战斗。当他们这么说时，公众惊呆了。他们以为战斗都在比利时。当法国政府说战斗其实已经深入法国腹地时，他们简直不敢相信。两天后，第一架德国单翼飞机飞越巴黎，在巴黎投下了五颗小炸弹。
Now, by this point, all public buildings in Paris have been closed. Well, the theatres have closed. Most of the shops are shut because there are, you know, so many staff are away at the front. There are thousands of refugees at the railway stations. The roads are blocked with traffic, and people have started building barricades at the entrances to Paris. It's like, sort of, yeah, it's like 1792 or 1793 or something. The same day, so now the 30th, the first report that the government is preparing to flee south to Bordeaux.
到这个时候，巴黎的所有公共建筑都已关闭。剧院也已经关门。大多数商店都关门了，因为你知道，有那么多的员工都在前线。火车站有成千上万的难民。道路被交通堵塞，人们已经开始在巴黎的入口处修建路障。这就像是，某种程度上，对，就像1792年或1793年那样。同一天，也就是30日，出现了政府准备向南逃往波尔多首份报道。
They're going to take with them the gold reserves of the Bonc de France. They're going to take all the masterpieces from the city's art galleries and museums. And at the British embassy, the staff are now burning their confidential papers. Because in just a few days, the Germans will be at the gates of Paris and the fall of France is at hand. Or is it? We will find out next time. And if you want to hear that episode right now, then you can join our very own Expeditionary Force,
他们将带走法兰西银行的黄金储备。他们将带走这座城市艺术画廊和博物馆所有的杰作。在英国大使馆，工作人员现在正在烧毁他们的机密文件。因为再过几天，德国人就会兵临巴黎城下，法国的沦陷近在眼前。真是这样吗？我们下期再见。如果你想现在就听到那一集，你可以加入我们自己的远征军俱乐部，“The Rest is History Club”，网址是therestisistory.com。
The Rest is History Club, at the rest is history.com. And not only will you be able to hear that episode and all the episodes in this series, you will also be able to hear us discuss the Angels of Mons, the archers from Agincourt, or perhaps they were literally, angels who came to the rescue of the British Expeditionary Force and changed the course of history. So we'll maybe see you for that.
不仅能够听到那一集以及本系列的所有节目，你还将听到我们讨论蒙斯天使、阿金库尔的弓箭手，或者也许他们真的是前来拯救英国远征军并改变历史进程的天使。所以我们也许会在那里见到你。
And if you don't want to sign up to that, that's fine. We will be releasing the next episodes over the next couple of weeks. So either way, lots more First World War action to come. Bye-bye. Cheerio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你不想注册也没关系。我们将在接下来的几周内发布接下来的几集。无论如何，还有更多的第一次世界大战的内容即将到来。再见。拜拜。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。